bonjour alors
petit propos liminaire
or après un tel coup de brosse à reluire
la barre est désormais placée
extrêmement haut puis elle est également
est classé extrêmement qu'on le respect
de l'horaire dont j'espère que je vais y
arriver aussi
et la deuxième chose que je voulais vous
dire c'est que je n'habite pas très loin
donc je suis venu à vélo et donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle je suis beaucoup
moins bien habillée qu'à peu près tous
les gens présents dans cette salle et
j'espère que voudrait bien en excuser un
certain nombre d'entre vous ont eu dans
leurs jeunes années plus récentes que
les miennes hélas des compositions de
philosophie vous savez la composition de
philosophie c'est on vous donne une
phrase et puis vous êtes priés d'en
tartiner pendant trois heures alors moi
je vais pas tartiner trois heures parce
que je les ai pas mais par contre je
vais essayer de faire de la philosophie
donc je vais essayer de décortiquer les
mots dans l'intervention que je vais
faire à partir de maintenant toutes les
questions de transition énergétique dont
je vous parlais un peu d'énergie dans
transition énergétique est aussi
transition dont je vous parlais un peu
de transition et enfin je vais vous
parler un peu de place du nucléaire et
de ce qu'elle sera peut-être ou de ce
qu'elle ne sera pas et ça va dépendre
pour partie de ce que feront une partie
des gens dans cette salle et des gens
qu'ils fréquentent quotidiennement
donc soyons scolaire et je vais
commencer par les j'ai commencé par
l'énergie en prenant non pas
l'enseignant que vous avez eue vous mais
le premier professeur de france
je vous présente le premier professeur
de francis est court il faisait courir
parce que là j'ai l'impression qui est
devenu un peu feignant mais il faisait
cours une fois par mois devant 7
millions d'élèves encore donc tous les
enseignants vous avez eu peuvent aller
se rhabiller 7 millions d'élèves à
chaque fois alors en général il apprend
ses 7 millions d'élèves des trucs aussi
essentiels que quelle est la couleur du
nez de la personne du personnage qui est
en haut à droite du timbre de 75
centimes datant de 1962
pourquoi bon bref mais on aurait pu
imaginer qu'il pose par exemple testé de
cette question qu'est-ce que l'énergie
soit dit en passant question qu'un
journaliste politique pourrait poser aux
milices de l'énergie moi j'aimerais bien
qu'un journaliste politique pose cette
question
parce que je suis sûr de la réponse
serait pas la bonne c'est qu'un mise de
l'énergie donc qu'est-ce que l'énergie
alors vous normalement dans cette salle
vous êtes à peu payé pour savoir de quoi
il retourne et je vous fiche mon billet
pourtant que si je vous faisais remplir
un petit papier blanc et bien même dans
cette salle j'en trouverai certains pour
me dire ça l'énergie c'est une facture
d'accord c'est un truc que se paye tous
les mois ou tous les deux mois je reçois
une facture edf beaucoup trop cher
évidemment si monsieur lévy en temps
augmenté d'un dixième de centimes le
prix du kilowattheure en belgique il
n'est pas sérieux pareil pour le
président des délices et éventuellement
une facture de gaz et puis pour les plus
avancés d'entre vous vous allez
éventuellement penser au point d'une
voiture et d'une facture si à qui que ce
soit dans la salle qui comme moi et
petits patrons parce qu'en fait c'est ça
mon métier et je suis petit chef
d'entreprise est bien l'énergie c'est un
ça va dans les comptes de classe si cela
c'est un poste de charge et comme tous
les postes de charges
nous nous sommes bien d'accord plus les
faibles mieux on se porte ça va comme
pour les salaires dans les postes de
charges et si ça peut ne pas des pro
helvetia
donc c'est une charge vous avez
également des gens qui ont aujourd'hui
le réflexe pavlovien non pas énergie
égale charge mais énergique à l'économie
dont on ne sait pas trop ce que c'est
mais c'est pas grave pour l'économiser
c'est ça qui est important
et puis vous avez des poètes si
important dépôt est surtout quand il
s'agit de philosophie et le poète lui va
vous dire l'énergie c'est ce dont je
suis rempli un matin je suis en forme et
bien les deux premiers ont tort et le
poète a raison puisque vous savez tous
dans cette salle où normalement vous
devriez tous d'avoir dans cette salle
que l'énergie c'est par définition en
physique ce qui caractérise le
changement d'état d'un système donc dit
autrement
l'énergie est la contrepartie de la
transformation
plus j'ai d'énergie plus en forme plus
transforme plus j'ai utilisé ou plus
exactement fait appel à de l'énergie
parce que vous savez qu'on peut pas la
détruire et pas la créer jusqu'à
transformer donc l'énergie c'est la
transformation du monde et de la
quelques premières conclusions majeures
à avoir en tête
elle ne peut pas être propre d'accord
puisque avoir utilisé de l'énergie si
avoir changé quelque chose
donc si vous avez changé quelque chose
pour ne pas laisser les toilettes dans
l'état dans lequel vous les avez trouvés
en entrant corps pas possible donc il
n'existe pas d'énergie propre ça
n'existe pas et quand vous regardez dans
la vulgate médiatique ce qu'est
l'énergie propre en fait vous vous
rendez compte que c'est une énergie qui
est utilisé en quantités tellement
infinitésimales que en particulier ses
effets indésirables sont minimes
le jour où l'énergie cesse d'être
utilisés en quantité infinitésimale ssd
propre ça marche avec toutes les
énergies
il peut pas plus y avoir d'énergie verte
vous rose ou bleu à paillettes ou chez
pas quoi l'énergie c'est la
transformation donc il ya certaines
transformations dont les effets positifs
l'emportent sur les effets indésirables
et d'autres transformations pour
lesquelles celle inverse
mais il n'existe ni énergie verte ni
énergie propre la deuxième chose
qui faut avoir en tête tout de suite
c'est que l'énergie on va parler de
physique avant de parler de quoi que ce
soit d'autre
et vous êtes bien placé pour savoir que
les lois de la physique on n'y échappe
pas simplement parce qu'on les ignore
les lois humaines c'est très facile d'y
échapper parce qu'on les ignore
d'accord je roule quelque part en ne
sachant pas que la vitesse est limitée
je franchis la limitation de vitesse pas
de radar bat flics et j'ai pas
d'accident j'ai violé la loi et il
m'arrive rien et je ne sais même pas qui
violaient la loi
malheureusement même si vous ignorez ce
que c'est que la loi de conservation
pouvait pas la violer donc tout
programme politique qui entend violé la
loi de conservation de l'énergie et y en
a beaucoup en ce moment où la règle de
trois tailles en a beaucoup en ce moment
où fera faillite
vous m'avez pas c'est les promesses
qu'on vous fait qui ne se réaliseront
pas et qui font monter les populistes ne
vous mariez pas trop je voulais dit
l'énergie c'est la transformation du
monde alors quelques exemples issus de
la vie courante où on va transformer
notre environnement et où on utilise de
l'énergie tout appareil à môtiers une
température utilisons l'institut de
l'énergie tout appareil à modifier une
vitesse l'utilisent ou restitue de
forme utilisent ou restitue de l'énergie
tout appareil à modifier une composition
chimique utilisent ou restitue l'énergie
à commencer par votre propre corps
tout appareil qui fait interagir un
corps avec un chant utilisent ou
restitue de l'énergie tout appareil
alors ça c'est pour dans quelques
dizaines d'années si ça marche mais en
tout cas il y en a une qui marche très
bien pour le moment de grosses bombes
thermonucléaires qui s'appelle le soleil
est soit dit en passant toutes les
formes d'énergie que nous utilisons sur
terre tout sans exception sont des
dérivés directe ou indirecte de
l'énergie nucléaire donc si on n'aime
pas l'énergie nucléaire la seule
question il s'en tenir parfois à bonne
distance mais sinon si on n'aime pas on
n'aime pas le reste est pas plus les
énergies renouvelables et enfin ceux qui
vous a beaucoup occupé entre le 1er
juillet et 31 août
vous avez également de l'intérêt de
l'énergie dans l'interaction matière
rayonnement et pour tous ceux qui vont
se marier pendant ma conférence quand
vous commencerez à tapoter sur votre
smartphone vous utiliserez aussi
l'interaction à thiers rayonnement
donc quand vous comptez l'énergie vous
conter la transformation du monde
alors là autre chose sur lequel je vais
revenir un peu plus tard il n'y a pas
d'économie sans énergie vous savez qu'en
économie il ya une grande notion qui va
servir à calculer la valeur de ce qu'ont
fait qui s'appelle la valeur ajoutée
dont la valeur ajoutée c'est très simple
vous avez unités productives comme peut
l'être par exemple ceva vous sortez de
sept unités productives quelque chose
qui vaut plus cher que ce que si vous
vous y rentrer parce que si vous faites
durablement l' inverse où finissait à la
barre du tribunal de commerce pour très
bien et entre les deux vous avez ce qui
s'appelle une valeur ajoutée mais entre
les deux vous avez aussi une
transformation si vous ressortez
exactement la même chose que ce qui est
rentré sans en ayant juste augmenter les
prix ça marche pas même un distributeur
il a fait une transformation l'objet
était ici il est là d'accord il a
déplacé quelque chose va changer
l'emballage donc toute activité
économique a besoin d'énergie j'y
reviendrai après en fait une des choses
que je vais vous apprendre c'est qu'au
premier ordre
depuis le début de la révolution
industrielle et en particulier depuis le
début des trente glorieuses le pib c'est
la quantité d'énergie qui rentre dans un
pays point barre c'est juste la quantité
de kilowattheures qui rentre dans un
pays nombre de gens qui bossent ce qu'on
s'en fout complètement et les largesses
des banquiers on s'en fout complètement
c'est au premier ordre la quantité
d'énergie qui rentre dans un pays puis
je reviens je voulais l'énergie c'est de
la physique alors la physique je le
répète est plus forte que les promesses
de campagne ce qui soit dit en passant
on va poser un problème à certains
d'entre vous dans cette salle le pose
déjà aujourd'hui le posera plus tard
quand l'élu promet quelque chose qui
violent la physique que vous vous savez
où est la physique vous avez la tragédie
de celui qui sait est-ce que vous devez
vous coucher en disant oui monsieur
gundam
je vais faire ce que vous me demandez en
sachant pertinemment que ça marchera pas
ou est-ce que vous devez essayer en haut
fonctionnaire responsable de tenir tête
au corps politique au dessus qui dit toi
j'ai pas envie de t'entendre moi j'ai la
légitimité des urnes pour moi alors que
toi tu es une espèce dans werder qui
m'empêche de rêver en vous allez
connaître vous aller de plus en plus
dans les décennies qui viennent
connaître ce problème c'est déjà un
problème majeur aujourd'hui je peux vous
le dire je connais un certain nombre de
camarades de promo nous connaissons un
certain nombre de camarades de promo qui
sont en train de devenir schizophrène ou
neurasthénique et ça sera un des défis
en ce qui va vous concerne et qu'est ce
qu'elle dit la physique elle dit il ya
une loi de conservation de l'énergie que
vous connaissez tous puisque vous êtes
dans cette salle la loi de conservation
de l'énergie empêche l'humanité de créer
de l'énergie en son sein d'accor sinon
ça merlin l'enchanteur et nous ne le
sommes pas ce qui veut dire que toutes
formes d'énergie utilisée par les hommes
doit être prélevée dans l'environnement
encore dès que nous utilisons de
l'énergie en fait cette énergie nous
n'avons pas créé nous avons été la
chercher dans l'environnement où elle
existe déjà une énergie qu'on prend dans
l'environnement et qui existent déjà
s'appelle de l'énergie primaire dans le
jargon des énergéticiens du pétrole du
charbon du gaz etc
comme l'environnement a été créé
gratuitement pour nous par 14 milliards
d'années d'évolution depuis le big bang
enfin 13,7 j'ai pu enfin dans ces
eaux-là gratos quand tu tu mens toutes
les énergies primaires sont gratuites
vous entendez souvent dans la vulgate
écologistes traditionnel on va dire la
phrase le vent est gratuit donc il faut
s'en servir tout à fait vrai que le vent
est gratuit personne ne paye rien pour
que le vent existe mais personne n'a
rien payé non plus pour que le pétrole
se forment donc le pétrole est tout
aussi quand tu que le vent l'uranium est
tout aussi gratuite le pétrole ce qui
n'est pas gratuit c'est de payer la
personne qui par le fait du hasard se
retrouve être assise sur le gisement de
pétrole
donc là vous avez deux options vous lui
ficher la paix vous la payez ou le
envoyé les chars et les avions les deux
options ont été prises dans l'histoire
toutes les guerres continental en europe
avait un tout petit peu quelque chose à
voir avec le charbon et toute la
tragédie du moyen-orient un tout petit
peu quelque chose à voir avec le pétrole
donc ce que je vous dis c'est pas eu
l'esprit de temps en temps on se dit
c'est plus simple d'envoyer les chars et
les avions que de payer ça nous coûtera
moins cher
pense-t-on pas sûr mais toutes les
énergies primaires sont gratuites de ce
fait ce que coûte l'énergie quand vous
allez là payer ça n'est pas l'énergie
elle même c'est le travail humain qu'il
a fallu consentir pour aller chercher
l'énergie la voile et la transformer et
l'amener à une utilisation autre que
celle que la nature en fête
dit autrement dans l'économie vous ne
payez que des hommes et donc ça dès que
la part humaine que vous allez payer
quand vous achetez de l'énergie
de ce fait plus une énergie est
concentrée et stockables sous sa forme
naturelle boisée sera cher c'est aussi
simple que ça
et donc ce que je vais vous montrer
maintenant c'est que de manière
irrémédiable et je vous dis pas ça parce
que vous allez faire du nucléaire c'est
juste de la fille que je me rappelle de
manière irrémédiable les énergies
renouvelables intermittentes et diffus
seront plus chers que les énergies
fossiles et pas un peu plus cher que
vous allez voir
prenons un volume d'air qui doit pas
être très loin du volume de cette pièce
en or de vendeurs je pense qu'on dit
accusant un recul de 10 mètres de côté
dans mille véhicules
admettons que cette terre souffle à 80
km/heure 55e pour ceux d'entre vous qui
font de la voile en général vous êtes au
port à vous sifflez des canons et vous
évitez d'aller faire le zazou sur les
flots faso si vous êtes dans un sous
marin en quelqu'un vous en fichez ou sur
un porte-avions qui est prévu pour ça
enfin si vous êtes sur un gentil voilier
de 35 m de 25 et pardon vont rester au
port
si vous avez le choix et bien si vous
faites passer l'énergie cinétique de 7
dans une éolienne qui va en récupérer
40%
vous allez récupérer dans sept heures le
même contenu énergétique que ce que vous
avez dans 3000 litres de pétrole mille
mètres cube d'air une grosse éoliennes
3000 litres de pétrole 3 microgrammes
d'uranium c'est la raison pour laquelle
ça sera plus cher l'éolienne
aujourd'hui vous délivre dufilho water
en sortie d'éoliennes à 6 8 centimes
sans stockage donc dit autrement faut
prendre le train quand le vent souffle
[Musique]
encore
alors qu'en face vous avez une énergie
disponible avec sa fonction de stock
avec sa fonction de stock
j'insiste pour 0,3 centime en tête de
puits donc vous avez un rapport 25 cents
stockage 25 à 30 entre les 2 50 à 100
avec stockage vous pouvez avoir toutes
les déclarations politiques de qui vous
voulez et toutes les déclarations de
monsieur et l'aude musk que vous voulez
de manière irrémédiable à cause de la
physique
l'éolien et le solaire ça sera un ordre
de grandeur plus cher que non et et les
énergies fossiles dire que c'est un
ordre de grandeur plus cher ça veut dire
que si vous payez les gens la même chose
il faut employer 10 fois plus de gens
dans le système énergétique pour sortir
la même quantité d'énergie et donc ces
gens là font pas autre chose et si vous
employez 100 fois plus de gens dans le
système énergétique luc aujourd'hui il
emploie 4 ou 5 % de la population aux
shoots
plus vous en prenez des gens dans le
système énergétique et moins vous sortez
d'énergie en fait c'est comme ça qu'il
faut comprendre la chose nous ne
passerons pas d'un système 100% fossiles
à un système 100% ou energy reviendrait
à la fin de cet exposé en payant la même
chose c'est une escroquerie
intellectuelle que de dire ça c'est une
escroquerie politique que de prétendre
s'appuyer sur des travaux qui dix ans
c'est criminel
ça fait arriver les populistes j'insiste
je pèse mes mots
c'est criminel
[Musique]
quittons crime allons à la montagne un
certain nombre d'entre vous l'ont
probablement fait d'aller à la montagne
au moins à côté de cadarache et des
montagnes est et il ya peut-être un
exercice auquel vous vous êtes livrés
certains d'entre vous dans vos jeunes ou
moins jeunes des années qui consiste à
prendre un sac à dos et se lever tôt le
matin et à faire de la dénivelée alors
on va imaginer que vous êtes en forme
comme mon pote de tout à l'heure et que
vous faire si ces 2000 mètres de
dénivelé dans la journée pour ceux
d'entre vous qui n'ont jamais fait de
montagne 2000 mètres de dénivelé c'est
six fois et quelques la tour eiffel à
pied dans l'ascenseur il est entré chez
donc vous montez la tour eiffel 6 et
quelquefois à pied dans la journée voilà
et si vous peser 90 kg avec votre sac à
dos c'est juste parce que et galen g h
c'est facile de faire les calculs pour
ça et bien faites le calcul vous allez
vous rendre compte que tout ce que vos
jambes auront fourni en faisant cet
effort c'est un ridicule demi
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique pas
beaucoup un demi kilo watt heure donc
vous transpirez toute la journée
en général on transpire un peu et à la
fin de la journée
un devis kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique imaginez que vous faisiez ça
un jour sur deux ce qui revient à faire
une étape du gr20 par jour entre le 1er
janvier et 31 décembre c'est à peu près
pareil et bien à la fin de l'année vous
aurez fournit 100 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique d'accord donc une
année de dur labeur d'un homme une année
de dur labeur d'un homme maximum
maximorum ça va vous fournir 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique dont
vous allez transformer le monde à la
hauteur de 100 kilowatts heure vous
pouvez aussi utiliser vos bras alors
vous vous appelez monsieur
schwarzenegger quand il était jeune pas
maintenant et vous des quais ses six
mètres cubes de terre dans la journée
avec une pelle
un peu le dos il reste toujours pareil
le et galen g âge fut la densité de la
terre qui est de 2,5 ne fait pas de
calculs je les fais pour vous dix fois
moins d'énergie mécanique mise en jeu
05/05 kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
d'accord une journée de dur labeur fait
ça un jour sur deux un homme qui utilise
ses bras ses 10 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique pas donc à nouveau
travail va vous transformer
l'environnement à hauteur de 10 à 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique par
dick et water pas sous forme et
mécanique mais sous son thermique c'est
ce que vous avez dans un litre de
pétrole
et je vous rappelle que malgré le fait
que la france soit un pays tout
nucléaire
un français consomme en moyenne 1400
litres de pétrole par an c'est pas mal
pour appliquer nucléaire non mille 400
litres de pétrole par an dans les
transports dans l'industrie dans le
chauffage dans l'aviation et c'est
évidemment mon pétrole me fournit 10
kilowatts heure thermique monsieur
carnot passe par là cette espèce
d'empêcheur de
de rendre on est jeune en zone d en
sortir que 2 à 4 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique une fois que j'ai
fait passer ça dans une machine
thermique m'enfin 2 à 4 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique c'est encore dans un
litre de pétrole l'équivalent de 10 à
100 jours de travail de force d'un être
humain
dit autrement quand je m'offre un plein
à 50 litres
je m'offre 500 à 5000 jours de travail
humain pour 50 euros tout votre pouvoir
d'achat
et là dedans ce qui a fait votre pouvoir
d'achat les études longues le divorce la
mondialisation les congés payés la
retraite à 65 ans le fait qu'on vive 90
ans etc
c'est tout tout tout là-dedans l'état
stable de l'humanité sans énergie
fossile 500 millions d'êtres humains 30
ans d'espérance de vie à la naissance
c'est ça le monde sans énergie fossile
donc ce que nous sommes devenus
aujourd'hui nous le devons au fait qu'
il ya eu du bon et du plancton qui a eu
la bonne idée de vivre il ya 300
millions d'années et que la tectonique
des plaques a eu la bonne idée d'enfouir
sous terre et le cuire à petit feu en
passant de manière sans oxygène pour en
faire un résidu extraordinaire fabuleux
qui s'appelle le pétrole et d'autres
substituts
donc je voulais dit tout ça pour pas
cher alors si je parle argent
imaginons que la personne qui monte sur
la montagne ou plus exactement qui me
fournit son énergie mécanique je la paye
au smic c'est que normalement c'est
interdit de faire moi même si on trouve
quelques petites astuces pour ça à ce
moment je vais payer mon kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique de quelques
centaines d'euros à quelques milliers
d'euros alors qu'en face la machine me
fournit le même service pour un coût
marginal de quelques dizaines de
centimes donc quand je suis passé du
travail humain à la machine qui mangent
de l'énergie fossile
j'ai divisé le coup d'une transformation
unitaire de l'environnement par un
facteur de quelques centaines à quelques
milliers
je le redis tout ce qui a fait le xxème
siècle divorce
erasmus compris hélas c'est dire que
quand on va parler de transition
énergétique
on va pas parler d'un problème des
jeunes ingénieurs à résoudre dans un
coin pendant que de l'autre côté on peut
continuer à promettre la lune sur le
plan social économique que j'ai pas quoi
etc
on parle de ce qui est au coeur de ce
qui est au coeur de ce qui a créé les
mutations sociales économiques
démographiques et le reste du xxème
siècle au coeur donc la transition
énergétique
c'est pas une annexe un projet politique
s'ils tentaient qu'on puisse présenter
c'est au coeur d'un projet politique
c'est pas annexes c'est au centre
si on remet pas ça au sens quand j'y
reviendrai peut-être à la fin si j'ai le
temps dans mes grandes envolées lyriques
je pense que nous sommes très très mal
parti et je suis pas du tout sûr que
l'on va arriver en 2050 sans avoir
retrouvé la guerre sur le continent
européen
je suis pas le cas je parierais pas mon
propre argent monsieur admettons
maintenant qu'on prenne un esclave donc
quelqu'un que je paye pas pour faire du
travail mécanique alors savez la
particularité des esclaves sait sauf
dans quelques lieux tenus secrets dans
paris envers les gens pas envie d'être
esclave si je prends un esclave
il faut donc que je prenne quelqu'un que
j'ai été cherché contre sa volonté ce
qu'ils me foutent un peu d'argent que je
dois empêché de [ __ ] le camp ce qui me
coûte un peu d'argent et puis je dois le
nourrir l'empêcher de mourir de faim de
soif de francs de chaud et ça va aussi
le côté un peu d'argent et bien si vous
mettez boutabout toutes ses dépenses
dans un calcul sordide mais qui encore
un à ses mérites
vous vous rendez compte que même à
l'esclave va vous coûter 10 à 100 fois
plus cher que la machine est la raison
pour laquelle l'esclavagisme a disparu
en occident selon moi c'est pas du tout
parce que votre code génétique fait de
vous des jambons alors que vos arrières
grands parents étaient des gens mauvais
je pense que vous avez exactement le
même code génétique
je pense juste que l'esclavagisme a
disparu parce que ça n'a aucune espèce
de rationalité économique de s'emmerder
avec des gens qui veulent pas de leur
condition et qui ne pensent qu'à vous
trucider qui sont pas efficaces
alors que la machine qui ne se met pas
en grève qui a pas besoin de dormir et
qui nous plaît pas je vous fais le même
job pour 10 à 100 fois moins cher c'est
aussi bête que ça ce qui est une autre
manière de dire que le stress
énergétique ramènera une tentation de
brutalité dans les rapports humains
sarah mènera une tentation de brutalité
dans les rapports pour le moment on vit
la première partie du mariage faustien
ça vous connaissez faustin d'abord c'est
super et ensuite la gueule de bois donc
pour le moment c'est super voilà la
première partie qui est super de plus en
plus d'énergie par personne vous avez
ici une courbe qui vous retrace sur un
siècle et demi l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne alors quand je
dis l'approvisionnement il s'agit bien
d'énergie en fait qu'on va donner à
manger à des machines c'est pas vous qui
buvait le pétrole enfin je vous le
déconseille et je vous déconseille
encore plus de mettre les doigts dans la
prise
donc quand on dit que les hommes
consomment de l'énergie en fait c'est un
abus de langage et un gros abus de
langage et vous mangez pas plus le
charbon ni le noyau d'uranium
en fait quand on dit que les gens
consomment de l'énergie il ya un
implicite qu'on a oublié de mettre dans
la sphère ça veut dire les hommes ont à
leur disposition des machines qui vont
utiliser cette énergie c'est ça que ça
veut dire et donc plus d'énergie
consommée par personne
c'est une autre manière de dire que le
parc de machines par personne augmente
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre quand on
vous dit plus d'énergie par personne il
faut comprendre le parc de machines par
personne augmente et à ce moment un truc
qui devient très logique c'est que la
productivité par personne augmente
si vous avez plus de machines par
personne et bien la production par
personne augmente si vous doublez la
taille du laminoir piloté par l'ouvrier
à fos-sur-mer la production par ouvrier
double aussi con que ça la seule chose
qu'il a fallu c'est un groupe d'un
laminoir 2 fois plus gros donc un peu
d'investissement est deux fois plus
d'énergie donc plus il ya d'énergie par
personne en fait ça veut dire plus il ya
de machines par personne donc la
consommation d'énergie que je vous
montre ici est un reflet du parc de
machines par personne c'est une autre
manière de dire la même chose vous voyez
plusieurs choses intéressantes sur ce
graphique la première c'est que les
formes d'énergie se sont empilées les
unes sur les autres ne se sont pas
calibrés lisez à quelques exceptions
près d'accord donc dans jamais on ne
peut dire donc ça c'est une pierre dans
votre jardin on peut pas dire le
nucléaire a remplacé d'autres formes
d'énergie il est venu par au dessus
mondialement localement c'est moins vrai
mais mondialement c'est un peu comme ça
que les choses ces crimes vous voyez
également qu' on n'a jamais consommé
autant d'énergie renouvelable par
personne qu'aujourd'hui on consomme plus
de biomasse qui a un siècle et demi on
consomme plus diderot qui un siècle et
demi et plus de nouvelle génération nous
v'la qui sont là
qu'il ya un siècle et demi donc si vous
regardez en valeur absolue
l'approvisionnement en eau l air par
personne n'a jamais mangé autant
qu'aujourd'hui c'est rigolo et pour
autant on n'a jamais autant utilisé non
plus d'énergie fossile par personne
qu'aujourd'hui donc l'idée que quand on
développe les énergies décarbonées
c'est juste ça qui fait le job et les
énergies carbonées diminue moi je vous
dis non c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est
passé dans le monde
c'est plus compliqué que ça c'est plus
compliqué que ça on peut y arriver mais
ça suppose des conditions économiques et
juridiques qui mise en place qui doivent
être des 6 ou des dieux je laisse savoir
qu'ils prennent tout seul non ça marche
pas bon et en particulier que pétrole a
pas remplacer le charbon parce que les
usages sont pas les mêmes et vous voyez
aussi qu'il n'ya pas de lien alors
retenez bien ça vous qui êtes jeunes
parce que ça va vous être utile dans
votre vie de citoyen il n'y a
strictement aucun rapport entre la
pagination dans le journal et la
potentielle dans le monde
je le répète parce que je suis pas sûr
que en une fois ça passe et vous allez
avoir du mal à lutter une fois sortis de
cet amphi contre votre tentation qui va
être de croire que c'est comme ça que ça
marche
donc je le répète il n'y a strictement
aucun lien entre l'importance réelle et
phénomène dans le monde et la pagination
dans le journal je reste journal est un
anti exercice de philosophie quotidien
puisque un petit garçon qui se fait
attraper par un pédophile c'est une
catastrophe
un million de gens qui meurent de la
grippe qui est une catastrophe donc un
égal 1 million je vous assure dans le
journal un égal 1 million et c'est
précisément parce que à égal 1 million
que une personne qui se laisse tomber un
marteau sur le pied dans une centrale
nucléaire en france
ça fait plus de spruce que dans la
presse que quelqu'un je sais pas qui se
noie en tombant d'un cargo par exemple
donc vous n'avez pas de rapports encore
une fois par contre il ya un rapport
entre le nombre de communiqués de presse
et la pagination après la raison pour
laquelle on n'arrête pas parler d
honneur c'est qu'à chaque fois que vous
plantez une éolienne nous fait un
communiqué de presse
donc on vous parle des éoliennes la
pagination dans la presse reflètent les
communiqués de presse des porteurs
d'intérêts
et pas l'importance réelle dans le monde
je vous montrerai un certain nombre de
trucs que vous voyez dans la presse
derrière en ce qui concerne le nucléaire
et même certains d'entre vous je pense
seront surpris donc je vous le disais
pour le moment c'est le début du mariage
faustien tout va bien dans le meilleur
des mondes
nous sommes arrivés à un niveau
d'utilisation énergétique qui est de 20
milles kilowatts heure par personne et
par an en moyenne mondiale - mondial
c'est une autre façon de dire que si
mère nature n'avait pas été généreuse
avec nous et ne nous avait pas donné le
pétrole le charbon le gaz plus
marginalement les chutes d'eau l'uranium
et le reste est bien pour que à therrien
et les mêmes conditions de vie
qu'aujourd'hui et les mêmes services
agricoles industrielles etc
il faudrait qu'il ait 200 esclaves à sa
disposition en permanence
c'est ça que ça veut dire en france
c'est plutôt 5 à 6 ans donc le smicard
français vit comme un nabab
il vit comme un nabab son espérance de
vie est de 75 ans alors que je vous
rappelle encore une fois qu'il ya deux
siècles elle était de moins de 30 ans à
la naissance il a à carros propulsé par
80 chevaux dans son garage qui s'appelle
une voiture alors que c'est l'équivalent
de la puissance du moteur
alors que le roi de france lui-même
était incapable d'aller à 120
kilomètres/heure même s'ils en avaient
envie il ya quelques siècles
il a accès à la médecine aux jeux du
cirque qui s'appelle une télévision il a
chaud l'hiver il a frôlé était enfin je
veux dire il vit comme un nabab
le problème c'est qu'il est victime de
la malédiction de tocqueville
c'est à dire qu'il se dit donc il ya une
personne au monde donc le smicard
française se dit tant que monsieur
verwaerde et gagne plus que moi le monde
est injuste c'est aussi con que ça
c'est aussi con que ça et sauf à
transformer la distribution des revenus
en irak
il y aura des gens qui seront pas
contents
en démocratie d'accord c'est le malheur
de la démocratie alors lisez tocqueville
si vous n'avez pas déjà fait c'est
extrêmement bien expliquer la démocratie
fédéraux speter comme ça la démocratie
fédéraux speter donc c'est pas parce que
smicard français en m'écoutant en direct
envahi suisse de la gueule de qui
moi vivre comme un nabab que c'est faux
actuellement au regard de ce qu'a été la
condition humaine depuis la création de
notre espèce
le smicard français vit comme un nabab
ou dans cette salle vous viviez connais
super la barbe et déjà le smicard
français vit comme un nabab les esclaves
du smicard français les voici enfin plus
exactement voici un tout petit micro
échantillons un tout petit micro
échantillon des esclaves du smicard
français ces esclaves mange alors ça un
petit avantage aussi par rapport aux
esclaves des temps anciens qui
mangeaient du sol et qui était donc en
compétition avec les gens qu'il servait
nos esclaves modernes manche du sous sol
donc même là dessus il nous emmerde pas
rond on a tous le sol pour nous et eux
ils mangent du sous sol s'est pas
complètement anodin ce que je vous dis
parce que si vous voulez revenir aux
renouvelables qui mangent du sol
notamment tous les dérivés de la
biomasse eh bien on se retrouve de
nouveau en compétition avec les hommes
ils fournissent quelques centaines
d'esclaves virtuel par personne
ce que je vous dis a eu un effet majeur
ou plus exactement à créer un malentendu
majeur dans la manière dont nous
comprenons l'économie future et du coup
dont nous forgeons les programmes
politiques futures en démocratie et donc
là ce que je vais vous expliquer est à
l'origine de la montée du populisme pour
partie vous avez appris à l'école que on
a un système productif dont qui produit
des tables des chaises des feuilles de
papier et des ingénieurs du nucléaire
pour avoir un système productif on a
besoin des deux choses
rappelez-vous les cours d'économie que
vous avez à l'école vous avez besoin de
gens qui travaillent encore
et si vous en avez pas c est bien vous
leur botter les fesses pour qu'ils
aillent arrêter de pointer à pôle emploi
et qui se lève le matin et on a besoin
de capital est ici les banquiers ne
prêtent pas on leur botte les fesses en
leur disant quand même vous êtes des
affreux jojos vous êtes priés de prêter
les grâce au travail au capital nous
avons la corne d'abondance productive
qui nous fournit absolument tout ce dont
on a besoin
et alors si vous êtes physiciens
ingénieurs ou edith web sauf que à
droite ce que j'ai c'est des ressources
transformer donc quelque part dans
l'entrée du système
il me faut aussi les ressources à
transformer donc moi j'ai envie de vous
dire oui c'est vrai mais j'ai aussi
besoin de ressources à transformer sans
minerai de fer c'est compliqué de faire
des fourchettes sans calcaire c'est
compliqué de faire des immeubles est
donc compliqué de faire des ingénieurs
du nucléaire sauf à ce que vous
acceptiez l'hiver d'aller faire les
courses ou la flotte et dans le froid
et si vous acceptez pas il me faut du
calcaire même pour faire des ingénieurs
du nucléaire ou du minerai de fer
puisque l'armature est en faire même
pour faire des ingénieurs du nucléaire
donc même pour faire de l'enseignement
qui est un service parfaitement
dématérialisés comme chacun sait vous
avez besoin de ressources vous avez
besoin de ressources
et puis vous avez besoin de la capacité
à transformer ses ressources puisque
manifestement une fourchette et une
poignée de minerai de fer s'est pas
exactement la même chose donc du travail
et ce travail c'est à dire cette
transformation j'en reviens à ma
définition l'énergie est alors de
grandeur que jeunes nous exposer les
hommes en sont responsables pour train
quand les machines et l'énergie en sont
responsables pour 203 moyenne mondiale
et alors là vous comprenez une chose
très simple si vous avez pour quelques
raisons que ce soit un couler
d'étranglement sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique en volume ton papa du prix
pour le moment on s'en fout du prix du
reste en volume vous aurez un goulet
d'étranglement sur le pib
même si vous avez plein de gens prêts à
se lever le matin même si vous avez
plein de banquiers compréhensif et je
vous montrerai un peu plus tard que
c'est très exactement ce qui arrive à la
totalité du monde occidental depuis 2007
et je vous dirai pourquoi 2007 et pas
1988 2003 ou 2045
prenons un exemple puisque c'est
démarrer dans la salle apparemment vous
prenez un chalutier du guilvinec corps
donc vous avez votre capital chalutier
du guilvinec
vous avez votre travail les marins sur
le chalutier il ya encore trois poissons
à pêcher à quelques centaines de milles
du guilvinec
donc vous avez des ressources et vous
n'avez pas de fioul
je ne pense pas que le chalutier du
guilvinec va sortir à la rame 4 la
veille j'ai pas l'impression
évidemment faut aussi des ressources
aussi à plus de poissons à pêcher vous
pouvez avoir les marins le chiffre de le
bateau vous aurez pas non plus de
poissons pêchés donc vous n'aurez pas
non plus de pib donc si à un moment
quelconque que vous avez un goulet
d'étranglement sur l'énergie ou sur les
ressources
ça devient le premier facteur limitant
du système est en fait ce que l'économie
classique qui a été théorisée il ya deux
siècles
à une époque où les seuls facteurs
limitants pour la production humaine
c'est-à-dire la transformation humaine
c'était le nombre de gens au travail et
le capital humain accumulé la théorie
macroéconomique a théorisé à cette
époque là que si avec ça qu'ils
comptaient les ordres de grandeur ont
complètement changé on est resté avec la
même approximation au premier rang qui
est fausse du début à la fin du début à
la fin
donc si un macro économiste vous
explique de quoi l'avenir sera fait ne
l'écoutait pas y aller au restaurant
vous gagnerez du temps
si la macroéconomie et et prédictifs
comme dirait l'autre ça se saurait si
vous voulez rigoler un peu confrontés
les projections de croissance des grands
organismes de place la banque mondiale
le fmi etc
j'ai pas le temps aujourd'hui parce que
l'on n'a pas laissé assez de temps mais
confronté ça avec ce qui s'est vraiment
passé
je peux vous dire que si chez moi le
type du marketing me fais ce genre de
prévisions ne garde pas longtemps
regarde pas longtemps alors dans le sens
croissant je vous dis ça marche très
bien vous avez ici le pib reconstitué de
l'humanité depuis 2000 ans alors vous
voyez que pendant mille ans la
croissance n'était pas un sujet
électoral parce qu'il n'avait pas de
préférence mais rigolait pas il n'y
avait pas non plus d'élections ceci va
avec cela un monde sans croissance et un
monde plus contre un quart monde en
croissance et le niveau de contrainte
d'un monde sans croissance ne permet
probablement pas la démocratie
en tout cas c'est pas sûr en tout cas
c'est pas gagné d'avancé jusqu'au début
de la révolution industrielle
la croissance est encore
elle existe mais enfin bon il faut un
petit microscope pour la voir
donc le taux de croissance qu'on a
aujourd'hui rendrait ces gens-là jaloux
mais en attendant c'est quand même pas
grand chose et puis arrive les
combustibles fossiles et or la crac la
corne d'abondance se met en route
vous connaissez probablement cette
blague de boulder un économiste qui
disait si vous croisez quelqu'un qui
vous promet la croissance perpétuelle
c'est un fou ou un économistes qui
parient son argent personnel la totalité
de son argent personnel transmissibles à
ses héritiers que ça va encore durer
indéfiniment
personne donc vous avez tous fait de la
logique dans cette salle si ça va pas
durer indéfiniment sais que ça va
s'arrêter un moment on est d'accord
c'est de la logique de base et à ce
moment la seule question c'est est ce
qu'on a eu l'idée quelconque de ce qui
pourrait provoquer cet arrêt et quand ça
pourrait se passer alors meadows s'est
attaqué à cette question dans le fameux
rapport que ça plaise limits to sorti en
1972 que je vous invite tous à lire
parce que c'est le seul exercice de
macro économie basée sur des flux
physiques intelligent que j'ai vu
jusqu'à ce jour avant qu'un ami qui
s'appelle daijiro de près de la suite et
essaye de faire la même chose avec de la
macro économie moderne mais lisez ça
c'est absolument fabuleux et meadows
avait dit
le résultat d'expériences est très
simple tant qu'on cherche la croissance
perpétuelle le système s'effondre sur
lui même quelque part dans le courant du
21e siècle et je pense que le pacte en
est le bon je pense que le temps est bon
et je vais vous montrer qu'en occident
en particulier en europe
je pense que meadows a déjà raison alors
pour le moment dans le monde dans son
ensemble il a tort et je vous présente
le meilleur modèle macroéconomique au
monde s'appelle et droite c'est sympa
les droits attaquant mais on n'a pas
besoin de s'emmerder avec des intégrales
triple je sais pas quoi les équations
aux dérivées partielles et droite même
moins à mon âge arrive encore à
comprendre donc ce graphique comment il
est fait il est fait avec un point par
année en allant de 1965 à 2015 et chaque
année j'ai mis sur l'axé horizontal la
quantité d'énergie utilisée par
l'humanité et sur l'axé vertical le pib
mondial en dollars constants une
simplicité biblique
c'est une autre manière de vous dire
c'est l'énergie qui détermine le pays
alors vous allez me dire c'est la poule
et l'oeuf
je vais dire oui enfin il faut love pour
alors la poule donc dit autrement ce
graphique me suffit à dire et je vais
vous montrer après le cas de l'espagne
mais y en a plein d'autres comme ça que
si vous n'avez pas d'énergie vous avez
pib il me suffit à dire ça
alors voilà le cas de l'espagne klum
sert marche ça marche ça marche ça
marche plus à part dans l'autre sens
bon là ça remarche un peu m'enfin ça n'a
pas duré longtemps donc toujours pas de
retraite alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
en 2005 2006 plus exactement il s'est
passé ce que j'ai montré un peu plus
tard que la production mondiale de
pétrole s'est arrêté trois points 2005
nonobstant ce que vous raconte les
journaux sur le pétrole de schiste
il s'est passé que l'espagne avait 50%
de pétrole dans son mix énergétique
qu'elle importe et où est donc la
production mondiale s'arrête à droite
tout ce que les chinois achètent en plus
les espagnols l'achète en moins donc ils
se retrouvent délibérément privé d'une
partie de leur approvisionnement
énergétique donc délibérément privé
d'une partie de leur capacité de
production
[Musique]
ils font le chemin inverse
je vous aurais montrer la grèce l'italie
le portugal c'est exactement la même
fait de courbes et le fait que ça tourne
comme ça c'est que vous avez d'abord un
sujet sur l'énergie avant d'avoir un
sujet sur le pays des c'est que la
chronologie c'est d'abord le frein sur
l'énergie ensuite le frein sur le pib
pour que ce soit à la baisse du pib et
engendre une baisse de la consommation
d'énergie ferait que la courbe tourner
comme ça par exemple si vous regardez la
crise financière dans les pays d'asie du
sud-est 197 c'est pas un problème
énergétique la courbe tourner comme ça
parlons ton du reste si elle tourne
comme ça et durablement c'est que vous
avez un problème d'approvisionnement
énergétique
[Musique]
alors l'approvisionnement énergétique du
monde ça vous le savez probablement
voilà à quoi il ressemble aujourd'hui
donc vous avez le pétrole qui est encore
en position numéro un et dans les pays
de l' ocde il est encore plus en
position numéro un
après bien charbon après bien le gaz et
donc les fossiles au total font à peu
près 80%
vous voyez qu'après on a du nucléaire et
l'hydroélectricité qui sont les deux
grandes formes de génération électrique
décarbonés dans le monde
le bois est encore quelque chose de
significatif dans leur ensemble et je
reprends ma petite blague de tout à
l'heure plus on en parle et moi y en a
vous avez ici le vent et le solaire
alors un truc qui moi me fait pas du
tout plaisir mais qui va quand même vous
intéresser
quand vous regardez l'un crémant de
consommation énergétique entre 2000 et
2015 dans le monde d'accord dont vous
regardez de combien chaque forme
d'énergie a augmenté entre 2000 et 2015
et bien le résultat c'est que le charbon
a augmenté 30 fois plus que le solaire
30 fois plus
donc si le journal avait une pagination
proportionnel à ce qui se passe vraiment
pour un article sur le solaire vous
devriez en avoir 30 sur le charbon qu'on
croit pas que c'est ce que vous ayez vu
je ne crois pas que c'est ce que vous
ayez je vous résume le pacte faustien
donc nous avons des ressources
naturelles gratuites dont des énergies
fossiles
ça brûle j'ai autrement ça permet
d'avoir des réactions exothermique et du
coup ça permet de transformer tout le
reste de ce qu'on a sur terre pour faire
tous les choses qui nous rendent la vie
si douce et dessus la structure
socio-économique que tant le medef que
la cgt considère comme acquises pour
l'éternité
deux petites questions auxquelles je
vais m'attaquer maintenant et ça va être
ça la transition 1 combien de temps dure
la corne d'abondance à la main
2 combien de temps est-ce que l'exutoire
reste sans réagir face à ce qu'on lui
met à ce qu'on met dans la grande
poubelle a causé le problème à mon
s'appelle le pic pétrolier le pic gaz et
le pit charbonnier le pic uranium enfin
tout toutes les questions
d'approvisionnement de ressources
le problème à valls appelle la pollution
au sens large et en particulier le
changement climatique pour ce que je
vais trier alors je vais commencer par
l'amont là je vais aller un peu vite
je vais vous rappeler un petit terrain
de maths le pétrole il faut 300 millions
d'années pour le faire en première
approximation ce qui veut dire qu à
l'échelle des temps historiques nous
avons un stock de départ qui donne une
fois pour toutes ça veut dire que la
quantité cumulée de pétrole qu'on pourra
faire sortir du sous-sol avec bolt
supérieur d'accord partir du moment où
une fonction à une bande supérieure à
une bande supérieure sur son intégrale
entre le moins affiliées plus l'infini
ni elle le peut être perpétuellement
croissance ni l2 peut même être
perpétuellement constante elle est
obligée de passer par un maximum est de
tendre vers zéro à plus ou moins
l'infini
vous vous rappelez de ce petit torino
match dit autrement b que vous avez une
ressource sous le sol qui est disponible
en quantité donnée une fois pour toutes
qu'il s'agisse du pétrole ou de
n'importe quel minerais métalliques qui
soit dit en passant donc ça vaut aussi
pour le tungstène le chrome le vanadium
etc vous aurez un pic à l'extraction
annuel de cette ressource
la question n'est pas de savoir si vous
l'aurez juste un théorème de maths la
question est de savoir quand comment si
c'est grave docteur si on doit le
provoquer par exemple pour les émissions
de co2 où l'attend une des conséquences
de cette affaire c'est que comme les
émissions de co2 découlent de
l'utilisation d'hydrocarbures qui
passeront par un pic à l'extraction
il y aura un pic aux émissions de co2
c'est une certitude mathématique
la seule question c'est est ce qu'on
leur a délibérément provoqué gérer ou
est ce que c'est une guerre atomique une
épidémie une famine ou dieu sait quoi ou
le déclin génétique parce que l'on surfe
sur les testicules qu'il provoquera mais
c'est la seule question c'est la seule
question il y aura un maximum aux
émissions annuelles de co2 ça c'est un
torrent de maths alors pour le pétrole
mondial vous avez ici une petite courbe
qui vous retrace la variation donc non
pas la production mais la variation de
la production de pétrole depuis un
siècle et demi donc il ya un siècle et
demi la production de pétrole avec des
moyens technologiques qui vous ferait
sourire c'est à dire une pelle une
pioche et quelques planches la
production de pétrole dans le monde
augmente de 15% par an tous les ans
après avec des moyens techno à peu plus
sophistiquée on descend même à 10% avec
des moyens encore plus sophistiquée on
descend à 5 % et aujourd'hui avec les
hydrocarbures de roche mère qui soit dit
en passant sont connus depuis deux
siècles
eh bien on est quasiment aux héros et
donc vous savez que quand la croissance
est à dire la dérive et d'une fonction
arrive à zéro c'est qu'on est au maximum
donc en fait le maximum de
l'approvisionnement mondial en
hydrocarbures
on y est en fait on y est quasi je vais
vous montrer après que pour le pétrole
stricto sensu on y est et tous liquides
confondus on y sera dans quelques années
souvent les gens se posent la question
c'est combien sera écouté j'ai pas le
temps de traiter le sujet aujourd'hui en
fait la réponse à la question c'est
qu'on s'en fout c'est juste pas de sujet
le sujet c convient je viens d'avoir
sais pas combien ça a coûté ses congés
en avoir en volume et vous pourriez me
dire il ya un rapport entre les deux si
j'avais le temps je vous montrerai les
bourbes la réponse et qui a aucun
rapport entre les deux quand vous prenez
une série longue sur les prix du pétrole
sur un siècle il n'y a pas le moindre
lien entre la quantité de pétrole
disponible et le prix en séries longues
pas le moindre à très bref délai ça
marche mais vous êtes en série longue ça
marche plus mais ce que je vous ai
montré précédemment c'est tout liquide
alors maintenant on va regarder type de
liquide par type de liquide et voici une
production de pétrole présenter d'une
manière que vous ne verrez pas dans la
presse parce que ça c'est des données je
suis pas censé avoir donc je vous dirais
même pas d'où ça sort
mais je sais qu'elles sont bonnes et
vous avez ici donc depuis plus d'un
siècle la production de pétrole or dans
le pétrole
on met en général deux choses on met ce
qui sort de terre sous forme liquide et
là dedans vous avez le pétrole qui sort
de terre sous forme pétrole plus ce qui
sort de terre sous forme de bitume et
vous transformer en pétrole la partie
sombre du bas les extras l'eau à l'état
et puis au dessus vous avez des trucs
qui sortent avec le gaz et qui ne sont
pas du pétrole mais que toutes les
statistiques pétrolières comptes avec le
pétrole
alors les liquides de gaz en fait c'est
pas lui qui la température et pression
ambiante c'est butane et de propane
donc c'est pas un liquide du tout et ça
ne sert pas à faire des carburants fin
sauf dans les voitures qui roulent au
gpl est ici vous avez des mots les
chaînes carbonées un tout petit peu plus
long qu'on appelle des condensats et qui
sortent avec le gaz aussi donc ça ça
augmente parce que la production de gaz
augmente par contre la production de
pétrole stricto sensu depuis 2005
n'augmente plus
elle a un peu augmenté en 2014 2005 et
elle est en train de se casser la gueule
en ce moment donc ça ne prend plus et si
ça n'augmente plus et qu'il ya des pays
qui en prennent plus et pas d'autres
entraînements donc ce qui est en train
de se passer avec le pétrole en ce
moment c'est que depuis 2006 les chinois
de plus en plus riches sont en train dé
20 c de la consommation de pétrole les
classes moyennes inférieures de l' ocde
celle là même qui vont voter 30 pour
exciter le pen celle là même qui vont
voter 30 pour exciter le pen parce que
on est en train de vivre le début d'une
décroissance matériel qu'on ne comprend
pas et puis les faiseurs de miracles
n'arrête pas de nous dire
élisez moi et le précédent il était nul
mais voir vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir
et ça ne marche pas parce que ça ne peut
pas marcher parce que ça enfants violés
la physique le pétrole bessan dans les
pays de l' ocde
depuis alors le titre est évidemment
ironique la presse vous fait croire que
grâce au pétrole de schiste
l'approvisionnement pétrolier des pays
ocde est repartie à la hausse
peut-être sauf que l'on voit ça descend
pétrole de schiste il a démarré hier à
vos parts dont il a démarré hier il a
démarré en 2005
alors ça a changé la balance énergétique
des états unis ça c'est parfaitement
il importe moins ils emportent toujours
beaucoup un un peu moins qu'avant mais
ça n'a pas changé la tendance de foot
comme le pétrole vous voyez qu'elle est
en haut là c'est la première énergie
consommée dans la zone ocde est bien la
zone ocde est en décrue énergétique
depuis 2007 sais pas si vous le saviez
journal vous en parle pas c'est très
facile
ces données sont publiques ces données
sont publiques c'est la raison pour
laquelle partout dans la zone ocde
depuis 2007 le chômage a réaugmenté et
quand il apparaît augmenté c'est soit
des décourager de l'emploi donc on les
compte plus comme chômeur juste parce
qu'ils s'arrêtent d'aller pointer ou
alors ils ont trouvé trois boulots
empilés l'un sur l'autre il bosse 15
heures par jour et gagne la moitié du
smic mais ils sont pas chez les chômeurs
mais c'est ça que on a depuis 2007 dans
la reprise de l'emploi pour l'essentiel
dans la zone vos cd et en europe
on est encore plus gâtés vous voyez que
depuis 2006 notre approvisionnement
énergétique est en baisse sauf sur les
nouvelles er mai qui n'ont pas compensé
le reste il est en baisse sur tous les
compartiments de l'approvisionnement
énergétique européen il est en baisse
sur le charbon parce que la production
de charbon européenne est passée par un
maximum en 1985
ça fait deux siècles que les européens
pape dans leur charbon n'a pas ces pics
ça descend le charbon est une énergie
qui voyagent plus 15 % seulement de la
production mondiale passe une frontière
entre la production et entre producteurs
et consommateurs
c'est essentiellement une énergie
domestique donc compenser un déclin sur
d'autres formes d'énergie par des
importations accrues de charbon ça
marche pas si bien que ça
[Musique]
nous sommes en déclin sur le pétrole
parce que comme je vous le disais il y
en a pas plus dans le monde et les
chinois empreint d'une plus grande
partie est si je suis un peu plus précis
l'approvisionnement européen pour 25%
c'est la mer du nord qui est en déclin
géologiques depuis 2000 et pour 75%
c'est des importations avec lesquels on
est en concurrence croissante avec les
chinois qui entraîne un plus gros
morceau
donc ça descend nous sommes en déclin
sur le gaz parce que 60% du gaz européen
à dire de la mer du nord donc le gaz en
europe sepa essentiellement la russie
contrairement là aussi est ce que la
presse vous raconte 60% du gaz européen
vient de la mer du nord et la mer du
nord est en déclin depuis 2005 donc
l'approvisionnement gazier en europe
décline et enfin nous sommes en déclin
sur le nucléaire or là c'est pas un
problème physique c'est un problème
mental
on a décidé que c'était cac à berck et
donc on en voulait - l'hydro est
toujours au même niveau parce qu'on a
expulsé des fonds de vallées à peu près
tous les gens qui étaient expulsables
donc on va pas en faire beaucoup plus et
quand on va faire le barrage de sivens
vrai que c'est pas simple c'était une
retenue agricole dans le course et c'est
pas les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
que vous allez au dessus qui vont faire
la différence parce que comme vous le
verrez à la fin elles sont terriblement
capitalistique considérablement plus
capitalistiques que le nucléaire encore
et donc vous ne remplacerez pas le
déclin de tout ce que je suis en train
de vous montrer par des nouvelles
énergies renouvelables ce qui s'est
passé en europe sur la production
industrielle en 2007 va continuer vous
voyez soit dit en passant que la
désindustrialisation de l'europe c'est
une vue de l'esprit 1 jusqu'en 2007 il
n'y a pas du tout de
désindustrialisation de l'europe
la production industrielle européenne
augmente
elle augmente il ya une diminution des
emplois industriels parce que comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure on fait des laminoirs
deux fois plus gros si vous faites des
laminoirs deux fois plus gros vous avez
besoin de foreman monde c'est ça qui a
fait le déclin de l'emploi industriel
s'est pas du tout le fait qu'on a des
l'industrialiser le continent alors on a
fait moins de veste et chemise et
plusieurs bus vont très bien mais on a
pas moins produits industriels - l'or
ont commencé à moins produire
industriellement ils voient que c'est
une tendance
grax et au moment où on inverse
l'approvisionnement énergétique donc si
j'ai mon propre argent à parier c'est
comme ça je vais vous présenter jeu
pareil la totalité de mon argent sur le
fait que structurellement la production
industrielle européenne à partir de
maintenant est orienté reste
structurellement et c'est dans ce monde
là qu'il va falloir faire des projets
d'avenir pour vous moi pour ce qu'il me
reste à vivre et mes gosses corps
si on essaye de nier cette réalité je le
répète on se retrouve avec des
dictateurs
parce qu'il y aura un tel niveau de
malentendus au sein des électeurs que ça
se terminera mal une histoire amplement
montré
l'histoire l'a amplement montré
voilà c'est la même chose dans la zone
ocde au sens large et tout ça éric d'une
tendance lourde en fait et je vais finir
la partie énergétique là dessus vous
avez ici le taux de croissance ou de
décroissance de l'approvisionnement
énergétique de la zone ocde depuis 1965
donc là dessus vous n'avez pas
l'approvisionnement vous avez la
variation donc la dérive et un et le
pointillé c'est donc l'année secondes et
bien ce que vous voyez c'est que cette
dérive est seconde elle est négative
depuis plus de 50 ans et donc le fait
que l'on ait annulé la dérive et
première il ya quelques années n'est que
l'héritage d'une tendance lourde démarré
bien avant
et cette même tendance lourde va
produire une baisse de l'autre côté
c'est le déclin géologique encore une
fois des combustibles fossiles
disponible en europe et ceci allant avec
cela voilà à quoi ressemble la variation
du taux de croissance du pib en europe
sur les depuis 1960
ça c'est quand les cheveux blancs dans
cette salle sont nés là des trente
glorieuses c'était génial + 10 % par an
fin + 6 % par an c'est merveilleux puis
plus un puisque à +3 dr ça c'est ce que
hollande aurait aimé retrouver
manque de pot on est sur cette tendance
là donc ils arrière trouvé du tout et ça
c'est ce qui va se passer plus tard
toute personne qui vous promet le retour
de la croissance en france est un
charlatan
sachez le bras c'est un charlatan et
donc si vous voulez et c'est là que je
veux en venir
e avoir plus d'argent pour vous dans un
dans une marmite qui globalement se
contracte il va falloir que vous fassiez
la preuve de votre utilité sociale
supérieure pour expliquer que c'est plus
important de vous donner l'argent avoue
qu'à d'autres personnes qu'on va devoir
d habiller alors je répète parce que je
pense que c'est important ce que je
viens de dire
on est d'accord c'est un peu comme si
vous êtes dans une entreprise qui est
pas plus d'argent et qui a toujours les
mêmes noms de salariées qui vous dit et
vous dites augmenté moi moi à ce moment
vous êtes sûr que quelqu'un d'autre
ailleurs doit perdre alors c'est soit un
de vos collègues qu'on diminue soit le
salaire du fournisseur compères à moi
mais à un moment quelqu'un perd on est
d'accord c'est la règle de base donc là
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est que le pib bessan et le pib c'est
la somme de l'argent c'est la somme des
revenus
c'est ça le pib par définition et bien
si le pib se met à baisser ça veut dire
que toute personne qui entend avoir plus
d'argent pour elle doit faire la preuve
de son utilité sociale supérieure qui
justifie que l'argent aille encore plus
chez elle qu'avant et donc pas chez les
autres
je vais vous le dire de manière très
crue pour le nucléaire si le nucléaire
veut survivre dans ce monde là il a
intérêt à travailler autrement plus
violemment qu'aujourd'hui son
acceptabilité sociale sinon vous aurez
peut-être patron dans 20 ans mais il a
toutes les chances d'être chinois en
chine
j'ai pas de questions
euh bon et ça c'est pour la zone ocde
donc vous voyez c'est pareil permanent
dans la transition il ya une autre
partie de la transition qui concerne le
changement climatique
vous êtes bien placé aussi pour savoir
que corrélation ne vaut pas relation de
cause à effet si l'on soit conclusion
qu'on aurait attiré du changement
climatique c'est ça et je vais vous
montrer quelques petites choses qui
malheureusement sont pas aussi drôle que
ça la première chose que je vais vous
rappeler c'est que le changement
climatique c'est connu depuis aussi
longtemps que le gaz de schiste alors le
gaz de schiste est connu depuis 1826 à
fredonia sur la côte est la première
exploitation commerciale de gaz que les
américains ont eu pour faire de
l'éclairage municipal c'était du gaz de
schiste 1826 à fredonia l'effet de serre
est connu depuis 1824 grâce à monsieur
fourier qui a entre autres choses donné
son nom à une universités grenobloises
je crois il a fait quelques petits trucs
annexes notamment de dire qu'il y avait
un effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
en 1838 monsieur poulet puis en 1860
sait plus quoi monsieur tine dalle 10
les gaz à effet de serre c'est la vapeur
d'eau et de gaz carbonique par dont le
dioxyde de carbone excusez moi
maintenant on n'a plus droit de gaz
carbonique donc c'est ça les deux
principaux gaz à effet de serre on le
sait depuis un siècle et demi fin du 19e
siècle
un chimiste suédois dont vous connaissez
probablement le nom aussi qui à l'époque
n'a pas jean pierre foucault et sans
maire de ferme
peut-être que sa femme usée la gueule ce
soir là j'en sais rien se dit tiens je
vais passer le temps et faire un petit
calcul et monsieur arrhenius calcul que
si on double la quantité de co2 dans
l'atmosphère la température au sol
augmente en moyenne de 4 degrés et
monsieur arrhenius profs qui l'avait
bien compris le mécanisme à l'oeuvre dit
si cet effet de serre additionnel arrive
sur terre ça augmentera plus vite les
températures aux pôles co tropiques
ce qui est très exactement en train de
se passer en ce moment plus vite l'hiver
que l'été aux moyennes latitudes et plus
vite la nuit que le jour
tout ça est une conséquence de sigma t4
1 si vous appliquez un même sens âge
radiatif à quelque chose qui part d'une
température plus basse
donc quand même sur plus de puissance et
bien l'élévation de température que vous
récupérez plus importante donc arrhenius
avait compris ça et enfin c'est aussi
pour rappeler que les modèles ça date
pas d'hier ça maintenant quasiment 60
ans je sais plus comment s'appellent les
noces 60 ans les noces de diamant
pourquoi enfin bon bref deux pattes ils
ont fait un truc précieux donc ça fait
longtemps
j'y arriverai pas que les physiciens et
les informaticiens essaie de faire des
choses ensemble
non je vais pas vous bassiner avec
l'effet de serre en long en large et en
travers je vais vous donner juste un
petit graphique pour vous faire
comprendre qu'on est vraiment en train
de jouer avec le feu et après je vais
vous montrer quelques autres petits
trucs qui vous montreront par exemple
que les syriens et peut-être boko haram
et les réfugiés qui traversent la
méditerranée en ce moment c'est déjà des
conséquences de cette affaire donc c'est
pas la peine d'aller chercher 2100 ça
commence là maintenant vous avez ici une
représentation schématique des éco
systèmes installés en europe si on leur
fils l'appel
donc si on ne supprime pas les
écosystèmes installé pour faire des
bâtiments de génie nucléaire ou notre
dame où des routes ou des ponts ou des
écoles où la place municipale d'orsay et
bien voilà à quoi ça ressemble ça
ressemble à des forêts ça veut dire que
à peu près partout
vous avez un climat raisonnablement
sympathique wicklow c'est suffisamment
humide pour qu'ils poussent des grosses
choses qui s'appelle des arbres si vous
allez suffisamment à l'est c'est trop
sec qui pousse pas d'arbres et si vous
allez au nord c'est trop froid donc trop
sec pour que ils poussent les habitants
voici l'europe qui à vingt mille ans
alors l'europe ya vingt mille ans est au
coeur de la dernière ère glaciaire vous
savez avec nos ancêtres qui pourchasse
les mammouths à poil laineux et la
physionomie européenne est un poil
différente de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
donc d'abord j'ai eu une mauvaise
nouvelle pour tous ceux qui rêvent
d'aller faire du nucléaire en suède et
en finlande
il n'y a pas de suède et a pas de
challandes faudra vous trouviez d'autres
destinations à cette époque là vous
voyez également que l'écossé sous la
glace ça c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour le 15 au rugby et vous voyez très
bonne nouvelle pour les actionnaires
d'eurotunnel qu'on pas eu à perdre leur
pognon dans l'eurotunnel puisqu'elle pas
besoin de rothen n ya pas de manche
le trait de côte passe à l'extérieur de
la grande bretagne n'y a pas de 6 et de
briques site non plus puisque enfin la
bretagne et la grande bretagne sont une
et une seule
alors ce monde-là donc est un peu
différent il ya trois kilomètres de
glace donc à une carotte de l'épaisseur
de l'antarctique posé sur la scandinavie
et le nord de l'allemagne
soit dit en passant c'est empêcherait
les allemands de faire les andouillettes
leur charbon c'est pas une mauvaise
chose
cette calotte de glace contient de l'eau
à l'évidence cette eau il a bien fallu
l'apprendre qui de par son rôle a pas
pris dans l'atmosphère et a pas assez
d'eau pour ça on l'a prise dans l'océan
l'océan est une baignoire dans le fond
n'a pas changé donc le niveau de l'océan
a considérablement baissé il a baissé de
120 m donc là aussi je parlais de mes 55
devant tout à l'heure ceux d'entre vous
qui aime aller faire du bateau sur la
branche pas de manche pourrait faire un
jogging sur la manche mais
y à sa grande soeur la qui est posée sur
le canada
le laurentides pareil énorme calotte
tout ça a fait baisser le niveau de
l'océan de 120 m il fait beaucoup plus
froid donc beaucoup plus sec ou qu'il
pleut pas et donc les écosystèmes
installé ressemble peu ou prou est ce
que vous trouvez aujourd'hui au nord de
la sibérie et dans ce genre de monde
charmant et bien la capacité de charge
de la france c'est cent mille bombes la
population un peu moins que la
population de wendy en cours
c'est ça la population française à
l'époque et la différence de température
moyenne entre ces deux mondes là la
différence de température moyenne
planétaire entre ces deux mondes la c5
ii donc quand le monde est passé de
l'état de gauche à l'état de droit tu as
raison de 0,1 degré par siècle sur 50
siècles
voilà la transformation que vous avez
eue alors aujourd'hui si on reprend 5
degrés il ya pas assez de la safer
fondre pour qu'on reprenne sans maman de
120 m même si tous l'antarctique fondent
et on se contenterait de la moitié je
dois pas mal par contre ce que vous
comprenez bien c'est que ce genre de
transition déplace les zones favorables
de telle manière que pour une humanité
sédentaires de 7 milliards de bons
hommes qui au surplus va avoir à gérer
cette transition à un moment où
l'énergie deviendra de moins en moins
abondante pour une partie d'entre eux
c'est une telle déstabilisation que ce
sera la guerre partout
ça sera la guerre partout alors ça sera
la guerre entre pays s'il en reste ça
sera des guerres civiles au sein des
populations parce que ça sera le cas où
ça va être la guerre partout donc quand
on parle du changement climatique on
n'est pas en train de parler du
coquetterie et d'un vice grave et onfray
voilà à côté quand on a terminé le trick
sérieux qu'on avait à faire dans la
journée
non mon sentiment c'est que si on ne
prend pas ce problème à bras le corps
c'est le problème qui va se charger de
nous enfin ou plus exactement il va
contribuer à quelque chose qui va se
charger je ne crois pas une seule
seconde du reste c'est un des chapitres
dans mon dernier bouquin dont vous avez
bien compris en écoutant ivre qu'il
fallait tous l'acheter
[Musique]
le titre c'est dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2000 sont évidemment cette
blague nous n'allons pas dormir
tranquille jusqu'en 2100 avec le
changement climatique alors j'ai utilisé
ça pour rappeler le fait que dans les
simulations climatiques on les pousse
toujours jusqu'en 2100 et du coup ça
pousse le message subliminal que rien ne
peut venir perturber l'humanité jusqu'en
2100 puisqu'on aime exemple de plus en
plus jusqu'en 2100 enfin que je vous ai
dit qu'on n'est même plus en plus
jusqu'en 2100 je vous ai dit
implicitement il nous arrive un grave
sinon on arrêtera dès m donc en gros je
vous ai dit en même temps tout et son
contraire je vous ai dit attention c'est
grave mais on va quand même se porter de
mieux en mieux économiquement jusqu'en
2100 donc si on se porte de mieux en
mieux économiquement jusqu'en 2100 pour
vous voulez vous qu'on sent bien avec le
changement climatique
donc en fait non c'est pas ça qui va se
passer
donc là je suis juste en train de vous
dire que 5 degrés ces massifs et au
surplus en un siècle c'est quelque chose
qui va être une déstabilisation massive
et une partie a déjà commencé alors ce
qu'on va avoir comme conséquence et un
affaiblissement du rendement agricole sa
a directement déclenché la guerre civile
en syrie etc directement à l'origine du
printemps arabe
vous allez avoir une atteinte aux
écosystèmes alors pour le moment on peut
encore faire disparaître quelques
lamentin et l'ours polaire ça gêne pas
trop l'humanité autrement que
sentimentalement mais enfin il ya un
moment où l'atteinte aux écosystèmes
nous gênera nous hein parce que si je
supprime tous les écosystèmes demain
matin donc ça c'est la borne supérieure
on meurt tous d'accord qu'il n'y a plus
aucun services écosystémiques sur terre
on meurt donc si peu rien ne pousse par
exemple on meurt tous donc il ya quelque
part entre 0 et plus l'infini un seuil
qui vaut mieux éviter de franchir
y compris sur l'atteinte aux écosystèmes
on va augmenter la biodiversité
bactérienne parce qu'on chauffe le
bouillon de culture je suis un foutu de
vous dire ce que cela produira comme
résultat on va augmenter les vagues de
chaleur ça c'est sûr
les sécheresses associés le niveau de
l'eau va monter parce que l'eau se
dilate quand elle est plus chaude et
quand vous faites fondre une partie des
calottes et des glaciers est allé
dans les glaciers et bien ça ce
transfert dans l'océan ça fait monter le
niveau de l'océan une partie du co2 émis
dans l'air est repris dans l'eau et sa
race et dicillo avec un effet sur la
biodiversité marine mal évaluer puisque
c'est une première nous allons modifier
la circulation à large échelle que nous
avons sur le globe et qui transporte une
large partie de la chaleur entre les
tropiques et les zones des moyennes
latitudes tous les phénomènes extrêmes
qui sont des phénomènes de restitution
rapide de l'énergie de la basse
atmosphère à la haute atmosphère et qui
sont basées sur des mouvements
convectifs vont s'amplifier parce que le
réchauffement climatique réchauffe la
basse atmosphère
mais symétriquement refroidi la haute
atmosphère puisque c'est de la chaleur
c'est du rayonnement infrarouge que vous
intercepté reste que vous interprétez
plus près du sol
du coup vous augmentez la différence de
température entre bas de la troposphère
et stratosphère donc vous allez
augmenter la puissance des mouvements
convectifs au sens large
donc c'est très tentant de se dire que
tout ce qui est hors agcs en ouragan
pardon tornade orages mais phénomène
cévenol etc tout ça va s'intensifier
nous avons commencé la fonte du
groenland nous avons mis en route la
fonte du groenland les hommes peuvent se
targuer d'avoir fait ça et ça va
continuer au moins la moitié bas-fonds
peut-être la totalité dans les siècles
qui viennent donc entre 3 et 6 mètres
d'eau de plus dans l'océan sont déjà
certains ça veut dire que les longues à
maman faudra la surélever à un moment où
il y aura plus l'énergie pour faire ça
comme un dément bah oui vous avez
également des stocks de carbone qui sont
aujourd'hui fixés dans les sols depuis
très longtemps qu'ils vont être remis en
circulation par le réchauffement de la
surface qui va avoir lieu
et tout ça va produire des conséquences
sur les hommes qui sont essentiellement
résumé par la dernière phrase que je
viens d'affiché qui est qu'on va avoir
des surprises
c'est que le dictionnaire est bien fait
surprise c'est un truc que vous avez pas
vu venir à l'avancé dont vous n'êtes pas
organiser pour par exemple la crise
syrienne c'est une surprise et vous
pouvez constater qu'on n'ait pas
organisé pour et quand on pas ça drôle
le printemps arabe c'est une surprise
vous pouvez constater qu'on n'ait pas
organisé pour qu'on trouve pas ça drôle
et des surprises comme ça on va en avoir
en quantité qu'on sente alors les
surprises ont deux caractéristiques
comme vous n'êtes pas organiser pour ça
crée des problèmes et 2 comme vous
l'avez pas vu venir à l'avance vous
n'arriverez même pas à convaincre
l'essentiel des électeurs en démocratie
que c'est de là que ça vient donc vous
continuerez à avoir un malentendu
profond sur l'attribution des causes
donc vous continuerez à chercher la
solution là où elle n'est pas et donc
vous ne serez pas le problème
le fait de se tromper de problème est
évidemment une condition suffisante pour
se tromper de solution à ce qu au quel
cas vous vous tromperez deux fois vous
réglerez pas votre problème et vous
aurez gaspiller votre argent sur un
problème qui n'en était pas un c'est
très exactement ce qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment en tentant de
remplacer le nucléaire par des éoliennes
on est en train de perdre deux fois on
est en train de voir le problème là où
il n'est pas et par ailleurs on est en
train de gaspiller notre argent qui ne
sera plus disponible pour traiter les
vrais problèmes
alors si on veut pas du changement
climatique
vous avez tous entendu parler de
l'accord de paris vous avez tous entendu
les fameux deux degrés de l'accord de
paris alors je vais vous traduire
physiquement ce que veut dire de 2
vous avez ici une courbe qui vous met en
abscisse les émissions cumulées de
l'humanité entre 1850 et 2100 donc c'est
combien de gaz à effet de serre ancrage
dans l'atmosphère en cumulé entre 1850
et 2100 et l'ordonné ici vous donne la
réponse du système climatique en 2100
par rapport à 1850 alors applications
numériques à fin 2015
j'ai mis deux mille milliards de tonnes
de gaz à effet de serre depuis 1850
enfin j'ai pas moi tout seul avec le
concours de mes sept milliards de petits
copains et du coup je sais que nous
avons déjà signé pour 1,2 ou 1,3 alors
en fait c'est n'importe quoi entre 0,8
et 1 5 à 20 6 mais disons 1,2 1,3 degrés
en plus entre 1850 et 2100 petit
codicille en passant tous ceux qui ont
entendu dire que au moment de l'accord
de paris on était d'accord pour 2 degrés
puis qu'on se reverrait dans cinq ans
pour savoir si on se mettait pas
d'accord sur un degré et demi vous
pouvez oublier le 1° demi il est déjà
dans le tuyau
si j'arrêtais les émissions demain matin
on a déjà les 1 degré d'accord
donc c'est très bien de faire des coques
ça entretient le feu sacré par contre ce
1° dit il est déjà perdue donc on peut
se réunir pour en discuter
demandez au giec un rapport pour savoir
à quelle condition il est atteignable
la réponse tient en un mot c'est foutu
pour le 20° demie s'est terminée comme
il fallait s'y prendre avant j'ai oublié
de dire que le changement climatique est
en cause et par des gaz dont la
persistance atmosphérique se font en
siècle ou au millénaire il n'y a pas de
bouton reset d'accord donc la notion
même de remise en état du système
n'existe pas c'est bon il n'y a pas de
notion de remise en état du système
donc c'est pas comme à warcraft ou s'est
il perdu la partie ce programme vous
appuyez sur le bouton reset et vous
recommencez
là ça marche pas là si on perd la partie
au sens de ya des conséquences qu'on
trouve désagréable
il faut vivre avec on peut pas les
évacuer l'accord de paris vous dit je
veux te degré et donc l'accord de paris
vous dis pas plus de 3000 milliards de
tonnes en cumulé dont 2000 ont déjà été
émises
donc ça veut dire que dans le temps qui
nous sépare de 2100 l'humanité n'a plus
le droit qu'à la moitié des émissions
que moi et mes parents et mes
grands-parents
on a eu à une époque où les hommes
étaient globalement deux à trois fois
moins nombreux
voilà ce que veut dire la corde ceinture
et vous le dire mais on veut pas de la
ceinture et à ce moment là première
partie de l'exposé vous dira que vous
l'aurez de toute façon vous mais d'une
autre manière
donc on va commencer à vivre la deuxième
partie du pacte faustien ou le diable
commencent à pointer le bout de sa queue
fourchue en disant allez maintenant tu
vas passer à la casserole et c'est dans
ce contexte là qu'il va falloir qu'on
trouve des projets d'espoir pour le
parieur show optimiste mais il va
falloir qu'on trouve des projets
d'espoir la seule chose que vous devez
retirer de cette conférence c'est que
ces projets d'espoir ne peuvent en rien
ressembler à quelques ça ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui très légèrement amendée à la
marge
ça c'est la seule conclusion solide que
vous pouvez en retirer et en particulier
il va falloir considérablement renversé
l'échelle des risques qu'on a en tête
jusqu'à maintenant
alors ça c'est plutôt une très bonne
nouvelle pour vous j'aimerais juste
après si on veut diviser les émissions
par trois il ya deux solutions ou bien
je prends chaque morceau des émissions
l'utilisent par 3 ou bien il ya des
morceaux des émissions dont je me dis je
vais essayer de m'en débarrasser
totalement parce que sa simple 20% alors
je vous ai parlé / 3 excusez moi si j'ai
encore droit à la moitié des émissions
passées jusqu'en 2100 vous avez donc une
intégrale qui est prescrite vous tirez
la courbe des émissions c'est très
simple les émissions doivent être nul en
2080 les émissions planétaires doivent
être nul en 2080 elles doivent être
divisées par trois aujourd'hui
ah pardon en 2050 par rapport à
aujourd'hui donc je prends les plus
jeunes dans cette salle
si à qui que ce soit dans cette salle
qui à 20 ans et quelques et bien il a
avec moi la différence d'âge qui sépare
2016 de 2050
c'est très simple oui je suis encore à
peu près vivant j'espère que vous le
serez aussi et bien d'ici là il faut que
l'humanité et diviser ses émissions par
trois si on veut tenir les deux grilles
donc on n'est pas en train de parler une
plaisanterie c'est génial que ce chiffre
était crantée et comme je le disais avec
josé paquito ça c'est le bon côté du
fait que les politiques comprennent pas
ce qui signe là ça a été non mais là
c'est fabuleux si ils avaient compris
leur est jamais si donc la tombe mieux
qu'ils aient rien compris mais c'est ça
que ça dit alors divisé par trois d'ici
2050 de quoi sont faites les émissions
mondiales 20% des émissions mondiales
20% des émissions mondiales sont le fait
de votre concurrent direct qui s'appelle
les centrales à charbon
donc là vous me voyez venir il faut
ferraille et la totalité des 1800
gigawatts de centrales à charbon
existante dans le monde d'ici à 2050 la
totalité et vous verrez un peu plus tard
que c'est pas avec des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires qu'on va y arriver
dit autrement ceux qui ne veulent pas du
nucléaire aujourd'hui veulent du
changement climatique
ils volent des conflits il vole de la
perte de biodiversité il vole de
l'acidification de l'océan et ils
veulent des famines et ils veulent des
dictatures c'est ça qu'ils veulent c'est
ça qu'ils veulent
[Musique]
7 % sont le fait de centrales à gaz et à
fuel c'est pareil ça serait bien d'en
virer une partie 6 % à 5 % pardon sont
le fait des cimenteries je vous signale
qu aujourd'hui la technique constructive
standard c'est ciment acier on ne
construira pas autant de mètres carrés
demain qu'aujourd'hui si on veut tenir
les deux degrés donc faut trouver un
moyen que les gens arrêtent de divorcer
je vous signale que c'est la première
cause de la crise du logement en france
l'autre jour je discutais avec un maire
il me dit toutes les demandes de
logement social que j'ai absolument tout
c'est des divorcés bah oui quand vous
divorcez faut deux fois plus de
logements
donc il faut construire deux fois plus
donc c'est pas une blague le divorce
amène la crise du logement
et je vous le fais à l'envers dans un
monde où on peut plus construire autant
qu'aujourd'hui ça sera plus compliqué
divorce est donc choisi ce lien
[Musique]
vous démerdez vous pourrez pas vous
faire pincer si vous choisissez mal
12% de là
des émissions sont le fait du reste de
l'industrie dans lequel la cie effet 6 %
ou 5 % en gros donc je le redis simon
astier et 10 % des émissions mondiales
la moitié des centrales à charbon
c'est pas des peccadilles 6% c'est le
fait des chaudières de bâtiments en
direct donc si ce bâtiment est chauffé
au gaz ou au fioul par exemple ça tombe
dans ses 6 % par contre l'électricité
que consomme ce bâtiment alors en france
puisqu'elle est bonne mais qu elle
consommerait en allemagne en pologne ou
en angleterre et bien l'électricité
qu'elle consomme à ce moment les
émissions des centrales électriques sont
dans la partie du hall 1 c'est pas là
c'est pas dans les bâtiments les
transports
c'est un gros morceau mais c'est plus
petit que les centrales à charbon doit
pas dire qu'il faut pas s'en occuper
chassons on est en train de s'en occuper
contre nous en ce moment avec la décrue
pétrolière en france mais ça ne
représente entre guillemets 16 % des
émissions dans le monde
6% vers les voitures 4% pour les camions
est en gros 2 et 2 pour les bateaux et
les avions alors retenez par exemple des
choses intéressantes
les cimenteries dans le monde c'est
autant d'émissions que le parc mondial
de camions
les aciéries dans le monde c'est autant
d'émissions que le parc mondial de
voitures encore donc si on veut
s'occuper sérieusement des transports ce
qu'il faut faire
faut tout autant s'occuper sérieusement
des aciéries et des cimenteries donc pas
monsieur hollande il accords de paris
c'est vachement important mais je veux
sauver florange il ya un truc qui
bouclent pas comment il ya un truc qui
bouclent pas
[Musique]
20% des émissions sont le fait de
l'alimentation et retenez qu'en france
les deux tiers des émissions dues à
l'alimentation des français c'est le
cheptel bovin les émissions de méthane
des ruminants puisque quatre estomacs
ils sont supérieurs à nous quatre fois
supérieur ça fermente là dedans ça rote
ça pète tout ce que vous voulez et ça
fait plein de méthane et puis les
déjections encore du méthane et puis par
ailleurs les ruminants ils mangent
l'ensilage et l'ensilage il a fallu de
produire donc fabrication d'engrais
diesel détracteurs les émissions de n2o
à la surface des champs quand vous et
pendez les engrais tout ça ça fait
encore plein d'émissions donc les deux
tiers des émissions c'est cheptel bovin
donc si vous voulez vous rendre utile
pour le climat planétaire manger moins
de boeuf ou plus de boeuf de tout témoin
de formage poulet ya pas de problème
pour se comporter d'être végétarien vous
précise moi je ne suis pas puis % c'est
la déforestation qui est un déterminant
amont de l'agriculture il se passe
actuellement dans le monde sous la
pression démographique exactement ce qui
s'est passé en europe aux états unis et
c'est plus de monde plus de surfaces
cultivées et on les prend bien sûr
quelque part donc quand vous appelez
vous n'allez pas les prendre sur la mer
sauf polders vous les prenez sur la
forêt là c'est pareil manger moins de
golf à croix blanche et plus de boeuf
accroît la pression sur la déforestation
et enfin 10% et le fait de bricoles
diverses comme la gestion des déchets la
fabrication des gaz fluorés qui vont
dans l'échelle de froid etc
alors voilà maintenant on va jouer
les émissions actuelles organisé par
trois alors est ce que je dis par
exemple j'enlève tout ça les deux tiers
de sa une bonne partie de sa et une
bonne partie de ça et puis quand même je
garde c'est pourquoi
le reste de sa r1 enfin comment je fais
a man show c'est ça la question
aujourd'hui
comment je joue c'est la seule question
alors dans les 20% de centrales à
charbon je le redis il faut ferraille et
la totalité de ses centrales d'ici à
2050 si on veut tenir les deux degrés
donc c'est une autre manière de dire que
faire du nucléaire à côté du charbon moi
ça m'intéresse pas je m'en fous
complètement de faire du nucléaire à
côté du charbon moi ce que je veux c'est
faire du nucléaire
à la place du charbon c'est pas pareil
[Musique]
parce que faire du nucléaire en plus du
charbon vous n'avez pas besoin de
regarder les gens qui ont des centrales
à charbon
si vous voulez faire du nucléaire à la
place du charbon vous avez intérêt à
être persuasif sur le fait que eux ils y
trouveront leur intérêt donc fois les
expliquer aux mineurs polonais ce qu'ils
deviennent donc tous les gens dans cette
salle qui entendent vendre des centrales
nucléaires à la pologne
votre seul sujet c'est qu'est ce qu'on
fait des mineurs polonais c'est votre
seul sujet expliqué que le bidouilleur
fait le tri beewi vont bien ce big horn
est ensemble et que le boulon de 12
écoles et là on s'en fout de ces repas
une secondaire ça le premier problème
c'est qu'est-ce que je fais des mineurs
polonais je vais avancer un peu parce
que l'heure tourne
alors je vais finir dans le temps qui me
reste avec je vais vous passez la règle
de trois et je vais finir avec un peu de
confrontation physique et perception de
l'opinion
manifestement tous les gens dans cette
salle doivent savoir une chose c'est que
casser un noyau d'uranium en deux c'est
pas équivalent à oxyder un atome de
carbone
ouais d'accord donc une réaction
nucléaire ne fait pas de co2 percer en
tant que tel oui alors un peu de co2
dans le nucléaire parce qu'il faut
construire la centrale donc ça cool
plein de béton du reste ce cochon de
deux rivages a expliqué qu'on allait
monter une cimenterie rien pour icloud
donc c'est bien que ça fait un peu de
co2 mais enfin diluée dans la production
future c'est en fait pas beaucoup par
kilowattheure donc pour un peu il faut
quelques quelques dogmes peur à quelques
engins dans les mines etc
mais bon ramener au kilowattheure c'est
quand même pas grand chose alors vous
voyez que les émissions de co2 par
kilowattheure que vous avez pour les
forces dites décarbonés ici sont
évidemment beaucoup plus basse que les
émissions par kilowattheure que vous
avez pour les formes dites carbone et
que vous avez ici ccsc carbon capture
and storage c'est les centrales à
charbon sur lesquels vous avez capturer
le co2 en sortie de cheminée mais ce
n'est pas efficace à 100 %
donc vous avez quand même des émissions
en plus ceci va avec cela vous avez ici
les émissions de co2 par personne pour
un certain nombre de pays dans le monde
et vous voyez la place de la france
alors voyez la place de la france
regardez où sont les gens qui roulent à
vélo dans amsterdam
on s'en fout du vélo dans amsterdam
c'est vachement bien pour les habitants
du centre-ville d'amsterdam
ça n'a strictement aucun impact sur les
émissions de co2 par personne aux pays
bas où ils ont une grosse industrie
pétrolière et gazière et où ils ont
plein d'industrie chimique ou dans le
grand amsterdam non pas dans le centre
les gens ou tous en bagnole donc
regarder les chiffres avant de regarder
la presse regarder les chiffres avant de
regarder la presse
en terme de climat les hollandais sont
les plus gros cochon de l'europe
après il ya d'autres petits cochons
quand vous regardez derrière vous voyez
les tchèques les allemands les allemands
sont gentiment cochons ils sont à dix
tonnes de co2 par personne et par an
alors qu'ils viennent nous faire
l'action sur l'énergie 22 à nous qui
sommes à moins de six mois je dis non
pas pour reprendre l'expression de la
guerre des boutons on est des couilles
molles quand on se laisse dire ça et
quand monsieur hollande dit les
allemands ce qu'ils font c'est vachement
bien on va faire la même chose c'est une
couille molle schaerbeek a rien compris
et là où vous allez moins rire c'est que
quand les gens du nucléaire le laisse
faire ça moi je dis vous êtes en train
d'être complice d'un nucléaire honteux
ce que vous êtes en train de faire
jette en train d'être complice un
nucléaire honteux il ya des manières
certaines plus intelligente que d'autres
îles de faire en sorte que on se tire
pas des balles dans le pied il ya des
fois où c'est compliqué d'y aller en
direct à ce moment faut faire comme les
autres pour y aller en indirect
parce que y aller en indirect quand la
raison de fond est bonne plus exactement
ne pas le faire quand la raison de bon
ou de fond est bonne c'est une erreur
c'est une erreur alors ça c'est la
réalité
voilà maintenant ce que les gens pensent
voilà sondage de l'ademe où on demande
aux gens qu est ce qui contribue aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
alors là vous voyez on leur a posé la
question pour les centrales nucléaires
et les centrales à charbon
je vous le cercle alors vous ça vous
fait marrer moi ça me fait pas marrer du
tout parce qu'ils votent tous et donc le
programme que vous le programme que vous
aurez derrière c'est parce que vous avez
dans votre cervelle c'est sûr alors donc
la transition énergétique est bonne pour
le climat
c'est que si vous voulez qu'il en soit
autrement
pardon d'employés encore une expression
triviale mais que j'ai appelé chez les
militaires donc on me pardonnera sortez
vous les doigts du cul non mais il n'y a
pas d'autre expression n'y a pas d'autre
expression fait ce qu'il faut pour que
ça ne soit pas le cas fait personne ne
va le faire à votre place sans prévenir
personne ne va le faire à votre place
absolument personne voilà autre chose
d'intéressant à avoir là c'est une
enquête sur la perception des risques
alors vous voyez on demande aux français
qu'est ce que vous pensez que ces divers
items tatillon de la route tabagisme etc
représentent comme récit donc en bleu
foncé un cd risque élevé puis etc
c'est à dire comme moi donc ça c'est ce
que les gens pensent et vous voyez que
dans l'échelle des risques vous voyez
arriver des déchets radioactifs assez
bien placés alors on est pas on n'a pas
de médaille
on n'est pas sur les trois premières
places du podium mais c'est pas très
loin derrière
et alors maintenant voilà ce que vous
disent les chiffres
eh bien les déchets nucléaires font plus
peur aux français que l'obésité qui fait
cinquante mille morts par an si on a
envie qu'eux ils pensent à autre chose
faut s'y coller faut pas juste attendre
que ça change tout seul si vous attendez
que ça change tout seul j'en reviens à
ce que je disais il y aura des
programmes électoraux des cônes en est à
ce moment s'il ya un nucléaire plus tard
et sera chinois en chine éventuellement
chinois en france français en france je
suis pas subir les français en grande
bretagne suis pas sûr non plus vous
voyez que les gens ont plus peur de des
centrales nucléaires que de chez eux
or je vous rappelle que chez vous est un
endroit très dangereux dix mille
personnes en meurent tous les ans donc
si vous êtes contre les centrales
nucléaires il faut avant être contre les
bâtiments qui ne sont pas de plein pied
[Musique]
d'accord soit contre les bâtiments qui
ne sont pas de plein pied et il faut
aussi être content électricité dans les
logements ça fait beaucoup plus de morts
par an que les centrales nucléaires je
leur dis il ya des faits et à la
perception que les gens manque de chance
il ya des gens qui sont plus ou moins
bien placé pour ça ici vous avez un
document vous connaissez peut-être quand
je suis désolé c'est un exemple c'est la
preuve par l'absurde de ce que je suis
en train de vous dire voyez l'irsn c'est
un graphique sur la crédibilité des
acteurs
ils se disent peut-être qu'il ya des
abrutis de conférenciers qui vont
utiliser ce genre de graphiques pour
faire leurs conférences donc peut-être
qu'on pourrait écrire gros parce que
peut-être il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
bien voir dans la salle
attendez c'est caricatural c'est
caricatural
d'accord je sais pas qui est le
responsable comme mais si caricaturale
alors joue quand même vous auriez
peut-être à lire donc dans les gens qui
sont pas crédibles pas vos régions qui
sont crédibles et légendes la recherche
donc par exemple si je prends le
nucléaire je pense s'est pas fait le
sondage mais je pense que le ceva est
plus critique et le cnrs l'est encore
plus et cnrs fait du nucléaire donc
peut-être qu'il faut arrêter de village
gaulois là aussi pour mettre les pieds
dans le plat
et si le cnrs est plus crédible que vous
pour défendre le nucléaire est bien
filer lui la patate chaude
non mais vous avez partie liée l'une ce
quillard serait très crédible qui dans
cette salle comme une star
qui ne connaît pas l'unique et plus
exactement dans cette salle
eh ben on devrait pas vous donner votre
diplôme non on ne devra pas
on ne devrait pas
je vous montrerai après ce que c'est que
l'unhcr je vous assure on devrait pas
[Musique]
là il ya un mec farfelues qui me fait
rigoler qui s'appelle bruno comby ayant
peu saoulant de temps en temps mais les
écologistes pour le nucléaire
bon voilà et enfin bref tout ça pour
dire que les acteurs industriels ckac à
berck donc quand je dis il faut que
quelqu'un fasse la pédagogie c'est pas
sûr que la pédagogie vous deviez demandé
à edf ou areva de la faire par contre je
suis intimement persuadé que si j'étais
à la place d'aidés est fait si j'étais à
la place de monsieur lévy je serais prêt
à payer assez cher
d'autres personnes pour le faire parce
que je finis là dessus le pib européen
se contracte donc la consommation
électrique européenne va se contracter
tant que vous êtes en compétition avec
de la surcapacité préfinancer dans les
renouvelables
vous êtes sûr qu'il y aura des morts
quelque part le seul critère qui peut
faire que les morts c'est pas vous et
c'est les centrales à charbon c'est le
carbone le sol
donc la seule chose qui peut faire que
l'on ait envie socialement donc tous les
gens qui votent la dont j'ai parlé avant
de préserver les centrales nucléaires
plutôt que de préserver les centrales à
charbon dans un monde où j'insiste il
n'y aura pas de place pour tout le monde
c'est de faire en sorte que l'échelle
des risques dans la tête des gens soient
comptés dans le bon ordre
[Musique]
c'est la seule manière d'y arriver
donc je le répète moi si j'étais à votre
place je serais prêt à payer assez cher
pour assez cher quelques millions pour
qu' il ya des gens qui s'occupent de
remettre l'échelle des risques dans le
bon ordre
je pense que c'est pas une coquetterie
je pense que c'est un facteur de survie
à 10 ou 20 ans
je vais vous montrer maintenant j'ai
vous démonter un peu le rapport à des
mots vous avez peut-être entendu parler
du rapport à des menaces sur le 100 %
venaient même pas mal toute
l'électricité renouvelable et voilà
alors je vous fais un break de trois
rives a dit que j'étais doué pour ça en
fait livre je te rassure à l'âge que
j'ai je ne suis plus douce que pour ça
je ne sais plus faire une équation
différentielle ya longtemps que j'ai
oublié j'ai un peu de mal avec les
dérivées partielles par contre avec deux
projets rivaux
donc je vous faire un acte de francs je
vais imaginer que on est un système qui
est effectivement devenu 100% vénère et
je vais le prendre 100% éolien et je
vais juste vous faire la liste des
investissements qu'il aura fallu qu'on
fasse pour être dans cet état d'arrivée
d'accord donc je me fous de savoir dans
quel ordre dont les a fait tout ce que
je vais vous faire c'est vous empilez
les investissements qui sont nécessaires
pour qu'on y arrive d'accord parce que
le système tel que je le décris à
l'arrivée a besoin d'un certain nombre
de composants exactement comme si je
décris un bateau je le dis je sais pas
dans quelle heure vous l'avez construit
mais à l'arrivée nous aurait mis de
l'argent dans la coque vide l'argent
dans le bon mis de l'argent dans les
superstructures mis l'argent dans le
moteur v8 de l'argent dans le même temps
le carré des officiers csu après donc
alors je m'en fous c'est pas mon
problème
alors on va commencer par aider je vais
vous faire une comparaison des
investissements si j'ai un système 100%
nucléaire on va dire le siège français
actuel mon facteur de charge du
nucléaire est en ordre de grandeur de
80% en premier lieu à 75 prenez le à 90
ça change pas beaucoup les ordres de
grandeurs derrière ça change beaucoup
l'équation économique pour aider est
fait pas beaucoup mon calcul l'éolien se
bat là quelque part entre 15 et 20% si
vous regardez les statistiques de
facteurs de charge europe ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'à la fin de l'année
vous regardez l'électricité produite par
une éolienne et elle est équivalente à
15 à 20% du temps à pleine puissance
il reste du temps 0 1
les mauvaises années en allemagne c'est
15 les bonnes années en allemagne ces
vins en france on est plutôt à 21,22
mais on en a installé moins que dans
quinze rames et on va dit autrement
quand je passe du nucléaire à l'éolien
je vais avoir besoin de trois à quatre
fois plus de puissance installée puisque
à la fin de l'année j'aurais produire la
même quantité d'électricité avec un truc
qu un facteur de charge trois à quatre
fois inférieur ensuite mon réacteur est
dur 60 ans l'éolienne dure 20 à 30
donc je vais devoir rejouer une fois
pendant la durée vimont réacteurs donc
je multiplie les investissements par
deux à trois ans 8 mai centrale si je
reconstruis système à l'identique chez
pas besoin de beaucoup touché au réseau
il est déjà là alors que si j'installe
des sources diffuses partout j'ai des
tas de raccordement à faire dans tous
les sens donc à chaque fois alors ça de
btp évidemment se frotte les mains
il faut creuser des tranchées poser des
câbles etc et quand vous faites une
connexion à un gigawatt ça vous coûte
pas mille fois plus cher qu'une
connexion à wattao coûte peut-être cinq
fois plus cher me dit on sait rien mais
la tranchée est à peu près la même
etc
quand vous regardez les chiffres
allemands parce qu'à un moment les
allemands ont plus la naïveté
enfin vous j'ai trouvé ça génial mais il
est malin il publie pu mais de publier
les chiffres de désinvestissement dans
l'environnement électrique en
pourcentage des chiffres des
investissements dans les dispositifs de
production stricto sensu et les
allemands disent quand j'ai investi un
euro dans le dispositif de production
je mets 0,8 dans l'environnement il
explique encore
alors moi je dis entre 0,5 à une fois en
bref donc je multiplie par ailleurs
chacun de mes investissements
d'accord ensuite si j'ai 100 % éolien je
vais devoir stocker parce que je le
redis sauf à ce que vous preniez le
train que les jours il ya du vent et que
vous ayez cour que les jours il ya du
vent ça ça génial parce que quand ya pas
de vent il fait beau donc quand il fait
beau vous avez pas court et quand il
fait pas beau vous avez course et pas un
système merveilleux ça donc moi si
j'étais vous à la place on le fout
traîne depuis hier par la fenêtre je
serais pour cent pour cent donc il va
falloir stocker si vous stockez une
partie il va falloir le stocker en inter
saisonniers d'accord il ya plus de vent
à certaines périodes qu'à certaines
zones
vous pouvez avoir regardé la par exemple
en france tout l'été tout l'automne vous
avez très peu de vent donc à ce moment
vous avez très peu de production alors
qu'on consomme même si on en consomme
moins que l'hiver de l'électricité quand
même le stockage inter saisonniers vous
oubliez les bat rien ça vous coûte un
bras et une jambe
un petit calcul d'heures de grandeur
vous montrent que pour faire du stockage
inter saisonniers sur batterie dans une
maison ça vous le prix de la maison
monsieur mots ce que sera content moi je
doute que yes marché
vous avez juste à caractère saisonnier
moi j'ai fait des calculs avec des
steppes donc je pompe l'eau du léman et
je la mets dans des barrages d'altitude
et comme j'ai pas assez de barrage pour
stocker 100 % éoliens en france
eh bien je multiplie le nombre de
barrages en france j'ai plus peur de
1,30 enfin un truc comme ça donc j'ai
aussi les coûts d'expropriation et j'en
tiens pas compte' la plus les coûts des
crs pour réprimer les manifs mais j'en
tiens pas compte en rigoler c'est
évident que si on essaye de faire ça on
aura ce genre de truc absolument
donc j'ai allégé mis un petit facteur 2
comme ça par contre de fête l'éolien
coûte moins cher au kilo watt installé
que le nucléaire alors là j'ai pris un
coup de 3 à 5000 euros 5000 euros c'est
quand vous faites un peu les andouilles
mais pas trop trois mille euros c'est la
chine
aujourd'hui on est plutôt flamanville on
sera plutôt à 6 peu importe ça change
pas les ordres de grandeurs non plus et
là je divise par deux à trois fois trois
fois deux fois trois fois de diviser par
2 à 3 vous faites le total
vous avez un capex temps des
investissements qui sont multipliées par
mégawattheure produit par un facteur 10
à 20 alors je vous leur fait d'une autre
manière
là où ça vous coûte 350 milliards
d'euros sur 60 ans de refaire le parc
nucléaire à 9
ça vous coûte 3500 à 7000 milliards
d'euros c'est à dire qu'une 1,5 à 3 25
années de pib français pour le faire
avec 100% éolien plus ce cas je fais un
bookmaker londonien qui paris la
totalité de son pognon sur le fait qu'on
peut c'est moi je prends le pari ne
compte pas totalité du mien non n'y a
pas de candidat donc on n'y arrivera pas
donc je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à
leur promettre ça c'est de la démagogie
qui se heurte à la physique donc ça
marchera pas donc on aura perdu notre
argent et on aura perdu la course contre
la montre est donc on sera rattrapé par
la patrouille et donc on aura un
effondrement du système etc
vous connaissez la suite de l'histoire
donc aujourd'hui essayer de singer les
allemands c'est pas juste une petite
bêtise c'est une énorme bêtise parce que
pendant ce temps là on prend pas à bras
le corps le sol vrai problème qu'il faut
qu'on prenne qui est décarbonée
l'économie nous sommes aujourd'hui on
n'a pas d'autre qui soit susceptible de
nous amener la reconstruction de
l'europe sur de bonnes bases la gestion
de notre hinterland méditerranéen et le
fait que en france finalement on fasse
du keynésien c'est à dire de passer de
la consommation à la reconstruction se
le payer pas adaptée à une décrue forte
en énergies fossiles
ça ça peut marcher dire qu'on va rester
comme maintenant en mettant des
centaines de milliards dans les yeux et
d'air ça ne va rien changer juste on
aura perdu deux points juste ça et on
aura financé les industriels chinois du
panneau solaire qui sont ravis on leur a
donné 100 milliards depuis le début de
la transition énergétique en europe
et pour vous montrer sa part les
chiffres voilà l'évolution de la
quantité de co2 émis par kilowatts heure
d'énergie toute l'énergie consommée en
allemagne depuis 1965
vous voyez les faits de l'énergumène 2
s'est pas manifesté la même quantité
d'énergie investis en france pas au même
moment
manifestement ça produit quelques effets
donc je le redis on peut se dire dans un
monde idéal 100% aux nerfs pour pas plus
cher et pas d'éoliennes dans le fond de
mon jardin parce que c'est laid ça
marche sauf qu'on n'est pas dans le
monde idéal et ça marchera pas le savoir
dernier point je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure de luxe car vous avez tous
entendu parler du giec
[Musique]
le giec est un enfant pour tous deux par
an pour tous qui sont le programme des
nations unies pour l'environnement et
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
donc deux agences onusiennes en 1988
font un enfant et l'appel le giec et
c'est un état c'est un organisme qui a
la charge de faire une évaluation et une
synthèse de la littérature scientifique
disponible sur l'influencé de l'homme
sur le climat
donc je prends tout ce qui se publie
dans la littérature scientifique et j'en
fais un résumé en 6000 pages quand même
ça prend un peu de place et bien le
parrain pour tous de gauche marié cette
fois pour l'occasion à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé fait en 1955 un
grand frère ou une grande soeur au giec
qui s'appelle une star
unitaid nation's donc c'est les nations
unies scientific committee
c'est de la science andy effect sur pato
me création et bien je le redis un
ingénieur du nucléaire qui ne connaît
pas ce truc là devraient pas avoir son
diplôme
vous devriez pas parce que vous perdez
une énorme justification à l'utilité
sociale de ce que vous faites une énorme
justification à l'utilité sociale qu'est
ce que vous faites
regardez le rapport qui a été rendu par
une statue pour moi est aussi crédible
que jake pas plus pas moins
sur l'accident de fukushima dont
évidemment vous n'avez pas entendu l'une
lira presse française en 2013 14
je vous laisse lire la phrase en rouge
je pense qu'elle est autoporteuse pas de
conséquences sanitaires liés au surplus
de radiation de conséquences sanitaires
liés au surplus de radiation moi je
trouve que ça serait une bonne nouvelle
si j'étais à la place du journaliste
j'aurais envie de dire ah bah voilà au
moins un motif d'angoissé qu'on n'a pas
continuons à avoir peur des démagogues
de l'obésité les accidents de voiture et
de perdre tout notre pognon au loto mais
au moins ça c'est pas la peine d'en
avoir peur non les mêmes sur l'accident
de tchernobyl on dit ceci dit autrement
il ya eu à l'évidence une augmentation
du cancer de la thyroïde chez des
enfants au moment de l'accident fois
chez les adultes
il y avait il ya une suspicion
d'augmentation de leucémie et cataractes
36 suspicion ça veut pas dire qu'il y en
a un sur deux
suspicion chez les gens qui ont
travaillé sur le chantier
après l'accident et pour le reste c'est
dans le bruit sont donc s'il ya eu des
conséquences elles sont pas discernable
par contre les conséquences discernable
à tchernobyl c'est je peux vous dire que
l'environnement la vachement profiter
parce que dans la zone interdite on a
évacué le premier facteur de pression
sur l'environnement qui s'appelle nous
et donc les castors sont revenus les
loups sont revenus les silures sont
revenus les éperviers sont revenus et
tout ce beau monde se porte très bien
donc on a fait un parc naturel
instantanément c'est ça qui s'est passé
à tchernobyl
oui blague qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
pack naturel c'est un endroit vous êtes
priés de rien faire c'est pas ça un parc
naturel
donc on a fait un parc naturel où le
surplus de radiation est un non-sujet
parce qu'en fait il n'est pas très élevé
alors que l'absence d'hommes est un
immense bienfait pour la vie sauvage
je vais terminer avec quelques éléments
de conclusion que je vous livre
là je suis absolument certain après tout
ce que je vous ai dit tu auras du
nucléaire dans 20 ou 30 ans la seule
chose que je ne sais pas cécile sera
français en france français en chine
chinois en france ou chinois en chine
alors chinois en chine je suis à peu
près sûr quoique deviennent l'humanité
d'ici là sauf si on s'atomise
complètement aucune grippe éradique
jusqu'au dernier homme mais sinon pense
qu'il en restera par contre qu'il en
reste dans de bonnes cirque dans de
bonnes conditions du français en france
mas servat des pompes pour partie de
vous ça va dépendre pour partie de vous
parce que je le redis en démocratie la
règle du jeu c'est que le système
remontant n'est pas décent dans les
remontant qu'aujourd'hui le monde
politique ça fait 20 ans qu'ils jouent
nucléaire honteux avec la france et que
ce jeu là il peut durer qu'un temps
taper sur la vache à lait en lui
demandant de continuer à cracher ses
dividendes même la meilleure marié du
monde finit un jour par pas trouvé ça
drôle
[Musique]
le nucléaire sol ne saura pas le climat
aujourd'hui le nucléaire je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure c'est 5 % de
l'énergie primaire consommée dans le
monde la vitesse de déploiement de ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour dézinguer les
1800 gigawatts de charbon plus créer
quelques milli deux réacteurs
supplémentaires dans les trente cinq ans
qui viennent pour remplacer toutes les
autres sources d'énergie c'est juste pas
possible donc ça ne suffira pas mais la
bonne nouvelle pour vous c'est que si on
dit on se place délibérément on augmente
la probabilité d'avoir le problème qui
se résout à nos dépens et à titre
personnel je préfère un milliard de fois
habité à côté d'une centrale et avoir
des déchets nucléaires dans fond de mon
jardin à 200 m enfin dans le fond de mon
jardin plus tôt
de continuer à jouer l'expérience qui
s'appelle des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre croissante et une décrue subi
d'approvisionnement fossiles en europe
qui nous amènera les populistes et pire
je préfère de très loin la première
éventualité
d'autres êtres humains et je le redis
nous sommes en démocratie 75 % des
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre sont le fait de démocratie
organisée tobin alors mettez le dans vos
toilettes c'est des chapitres de cinq
pages
donc c'est parfaitement adaptés captage
prenez les chapitres un peu long pour
les jours où les dragées fuca n'ont pas
fait effet
les plus courts pour les autres jours
non mais vraiment c'est il faut il faut
relire tocqueville relisez tocqueville
si vous vous poser la moindre question
sur le fonctionnement du monde politique
lisez ou relisez tocqueville ya pas une
virgule a changé et ça a été écrit en
1840 pas une virgule a changé donc la
démocratie est un système remontant donc
tout les gens qui se disent mais que
font les politiques c'est très simple
ils font ce que demandent aux électeurs
et pour finir là-dessus quand monsieur
sarkozy fait une petite déclaration
climato sceptiques il ne fait rien
d'autre que la chasse à l'électeur
traditionnels il sait que les électeurs
du front national sont plus climato
sceptiques que les autres parce qu'être
climato sceptiques c'est pas douter de
la science c'est ne pas avoir envie de
la conséquence logique du changement
climatique c'est ça qui bat au cetic
enfin pour une bonne partie
donc les électeurs du front national qui
sont des gens qui sont mal lotis
économiquement se distinguent contrainte
de plus alors que déjà j'ai du mal à
joindre les deux bouts
donc j'en ai pas envie donc ça serait
quand même mieux si le changement
climatique ça existait pas et tout ça
procède d'un vaste complot qui pilotent
ma vie et sur laquelle je ne suis pas
maître et bat sarkozy veut juste rallier
ces gens là c'est juste aussi d'être
j'ai été un peu long mais je crois qu'il
reste quinze minutes de pause que vous
pouvez transformer en question si vous
voulez et je suis désolé d'avoir été
moins stricts dans les horaires que les
gens qui m'ont précédé
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur jancovici pour cette
conférence donc je vous propose
effectivement une phase de questions
alors la tradition veut que ce soir les
étudiants du génie atomique qui commence
par poser une question en espérant
qu'ils en ont et puis ensuite le reste
de l'assemblée effectivement on peut se
prendre dix minutes pour pour cette
phase de questions
[Musique]
alors qui mettons qu'on remplace les
centrales à charbon par les centrales
nucléaires pour décarbonés la production
d'électricité on remplacerait une
production de co2 par une production de
vapeur d'eau et attend vos cela il était
écrit que les deux principaux gaz à
effet de serre était le co2 et la vapeur
d'eau donc est ce qu'on voudrait une
petite partie déjà du problème en fait
ce que vous dites c'est que l'on
pourrait croire la croix tout ou
remplacer une cause par une autre qu'est
ce que c'est une centrale
laquelle
[Musique]
jouer bien à charbon
ça fait aussi de la vapeur d'eau
qu'est ce que c'est
ok j'ai perdu
alors ça c'est la partie amusante de la
réponse la partie sérieuse de la réponse
c'est que la terre est une énorme
machine à évaporer couverte aux deux
tiers de ces ans donc les émissions
anthropiques enfin humaines de vapeur
d'eau sont sans effet sur le changement
climatique
merci à toi d'avoir un effet locale
pendant que le micro passe ailleurs par
exemple la mise en eau du barrage
d'assouan à augmenter l'effet de serre
dans cette zone
tellement damidot et ça ça a un peu
modifié le climat local
c'est globalement les émissions
anthropiques de vapeur d'eau c'est un
non sujet bonjour monsieur vous nous
avez fait un bel exercice de
communication notamment nous incitant à
communiquer plus vernon nos la
population française quels sont les
modes que vous nous préconisé pour pour
le futur un des films des des discours
politiques aller plus vers le politique
ou plus vers le peuple
qu'est-ce que vous puissiez je me suis
fait un peu connaître de la presse en
faisant un exercice que je vous
recommande à tout ce qui s'appelle
écrire aux journalistes je leur ai
jamais dit je veux être interviewé jeu
juste quand je voyais une bêtise dans un
article leur envoyer un mot en leur
disant vous savez là vous avez écrit
telle chose
je pense que c'est pas vrai regarder
telle source vous dis que c'est pas vrai
tels chiffres etc
à force de ça peut finir par produire
des résultats parce que journaliste ans
d'art en général ici incendié parce
qu'il a mal écrit le nom des habitants
de port-au-prince pas comment on dit les
habitants de port au prince les port au
princiens c'est pourquoi bon bref quand
il se plante sur ce genre de truc là ils
reçoivent
sinon c'est très rare qu'ils reçoivent
des trucs un peu argumentée alors fait
ça parce que la presse état prescripteur
très fort sur l'opinion la deuxième
chose c'est que il faut trouver au sein
de cette population des gens qui sont là
alors fait ça entraînez-vous à petite
échelle et après peut-être qu'un jour
vous entraînerez à plus grande échelle
donc il faut des gens qui soient
disponibles pour aller sur les plateaux
de télé moi je trouve ça intéressant que
quand par exemple vous faites un
téléphone sonne sur france inter sur le
nucléaire
il ya deux personnes ou trois personnes
en france qui sont éventuellement
susceptibles d'y aller juste pour dire
ce que c'est il faudrait qu'on ait 50
parce qu'en face il ya 50 et enfin s'ils
sont payés pour être disponible une ong
anti une partie de son effectif c'est
juste des gens qui sont payés par
disponibles donc il faut des gens qui
sont un peu d'histoire mais c'est plus
compliqué quand vous êtes ingénieur en
poste quelque part parce que votre
patron vous paye pas pour aller poser à
la radio donc il faut des gens qui
soient disponibles pour ça ça se trouve
mais donc les deux grands endroits on
peut faire de la le premier truc qu'on
peut faire j'insiste et ce à n'importe
qui d'entre vous peut le faire c'est
d'écrire un journaliste quand vous voyez
quelque chose passe et qui concerne de
près ou de loin le nucléaire et qui ne
tient pas compte des faits observables
on vous parle de fukushima orienter les
surligneurs en disant tiens c'est quand
même marrant il ya ce truc là pourquoi
vous en parlez pas à la dixième fois
soit le truc ça les emmerde pas ce que
vous leur dites en creux vous faites mal
notre métier alors même si c'est vrai
mais enfin même si ça les énerve
ils vont finir par se dire quand même
oui effectivement il ya quelque part il
ya un bol
donc ça c'est vraiment un truc que vous
pouvez faire demain matin après il ya
tout ce qui est vulgarisation dans
l'établissement d'enseignement qui est
quelque chose qui est très facile à
faire aussi pour peu que vous ayez un
peu de temps pour ça ce programme de
manière beaucoup plus facile j'ai envie
de dire
et quand ça se met en place à une
échelle un peu significatif ça peut
avoir des effets structurants il a tout
ce qui est la conférence citoyenne entre
guillemets c'est à dire je met d'accord
avec mon maire et puis je fais de temps
en temps des petites réunions
d'informations ici et là ça avec la
suède à apaiser son débat sur les
déchets nucléaires
parce qu'elle a payé une dame que
j'avais rencontré qui affichent par
combien 500 5000-10000 arrière cuisine
par groupe de 20 pour expliquer qu'elle
était plan se doit je pense qu'on
devrait s'inspirer de ce genre d'exemple
encore une fois ça demande un peu de
temps ça demande un peu de moyens mais
enfin si vous croyez à ce que je viens
de vous raconter je pense que le temps
il justifié
[Musique]
et écrire aux journalistes insistant
c'est un truc qui marche pour trouver la
syntaxe d'un journaliste or en général
vous finissez par y arriver c'est assez
simple sinon envoyez moi un mot et je
vous aide
[Musique]
alors pour nous dit de merci pour le
conférencier positif il faut croire en
ce que vous dites moyen pendant lequel
j'ai du mal à vous croire c'est que d'un
côté on dit qu'il faut une folle au
nucléaire pour éviter tout ce qui est à
dire régimes autoritaires mais on a pu
voir que la majorité des populations
étaient pas cultiver pour pouvoir
l'accepter correctement vous pensé au
plus tôt que ces photos là s'il faudrait
quelque chose quelqu'un de ma régime
suffisamment autoritaire pour pouvoir
l'imposer
il y avait hier soir 1 10 un
documentaire sur eva braun sur la chaîne
parlementaire je suis pas très pressé de
voir ce genre de truc revenir si c'est
ça la condition nécessaire pour qu'on se
sorte
une pense que ça aura quelques petits
effets de bord il n'est pas sûr que vous
même vous soyez du bon côté de la
barrière
donc je préfère qu'on commence par jouer
la carte qui est essayé de parler à des
gens qui quoi qu'on puisse en penser
sont pas si cons qu'ils ne puissent rien
comprendre si vous prenez le temps de
leur expliquer donc j'ai fait ce genre
de conférence en version un peu plus
simple de vendée c'est ap demander si ap
on y arrive qui va vouloir montrer des
trucs qui montent et qui descendent leur
montrer les images on y arrive il faut
juste se creuser un peu la cervelle donc
je pense que c'est plus vite fait
d'essayer de quoi en tout cas l'effort
me paraît être plus intéressant pour
passer du temps à expliquer de quoi il
retourne
plutôt que de se dire une fois que même
le plein sens au pouvoir faire ce qu'il
faut pour complètement persuadé que
c'est ça qui va se passer et encore
moins avec monsieur train parce que le
jour où vous aurez quelques ares à point
il vous ne choisiraient pas
[Musique]
il
il ya une question là bas mais je sais
pas si bravo pour cette conférence très
très dynamique c'était très intéressant
la comparaison du capex en cadeau
l'éolien et dans le cas du nucléaire
on aimerait avoir la même pour le
photovoltaïque
parce que c'est vrai que le
photovoltaïque a quand même baissé de
façon spectaculaire ces coups un facteur
120 ans et puis alors certes on attend
peut-être un plateau c'est vrai qu'il
est très aidée dans les investissements
par les politiques publiques très
volontariste mais est ce que il n'ya pas
quand même là quelque chose qui peut
être complémentaire du nucléaire avec
certes tous les effets des
intermittences également si vous
regardez le photovoltaïque
malheureusement le résultat c'est qu'en
bas vous n'avez pas 10 à 20 mai 20 à 40
parce que vous n'avez pas de gros
changements ici vous avez un changement
là parce que le facteur de charge est
plutôt de 10%
vous avez un changement là parce que le
stockage inter saisonniers encore plus
important j'ai fait des abaques et le
solaire et 80% de la production est
concentrée sur 20 % des heures
donc vous avez un énorme besoin de
stockage inter saisonniers et comme vous
avez un gros besoins de stockage tout ce
qui est stocké vous devez surdimensionné
le parc pour les pertes dues au stockage
donc et le coup au kilo watt installé du
pv est à peu près dans les mêmes zones
1500 dans les deux cas de figure si vous
faites les centrales au sol donc
malheureusement ça sera encore plus
élevée et par ailleurs vous avez un
besoin de consommation en matériaux qui
est considérablement plus élevé il ya un
chercheur du cnrs à grenoble dont
j'oublie le nom à l'instant mais ça va
me revenir peut-être qui a fait qui a
publié un papier sur la consommation de
métal par kilowattheure produit selon
les modes de production et les modes
dits décentralisées sont un voire deux
ordres de grandeur au dessus des mode
centralisé sur la consommation de
certains métaux par kilowattheure en
particulier parce qu'il faut faire les
supports des panneaux le machin a
augmenté les câbles les pylônes trouve
donc dans un monde contraint en
ressources
le grand paradoxe est que si vous avez
déjà un réseau vous avez beaucoup plus
intérêt à garder des mots de centraliser
que lé décentralisée donc l'internet de
l'énergie chère à monsieur riche l'insee
encore quatre intrus qui passent pas la
règle de trois
[Musique]
une question de nature historique le
plan b ce père est passé devant
l'assemblée nationale la reine
superphénix a été un décret pourtant le
nucléaire passe pour ne pas être
démocratique
on constate qui a une de manière très
très majoritaire dans la presse les
journalistes sont anti nucléaires et je
sais pas d'où ça vient alors je vais
tenter une explication qui va peut-être
je me suis souvent posé la question je
crois que j'ai quelques éléments de
réponse qui font appel aux aider à ce
que je vais dire
le premier élément de réponse est que en
france on a une presque et pour partie
publique or tu sais que le journaliste
art acteurs de montrer qu'il est
indépendant
si tu es journaliste et payés par l'état
quelle est la première chose que tu vas
avoir envie de faire pour montrer que tu
indépendance et dire du mal de l'état
donc les journalistes au service public
aime dire du mal des juges des policiers
l'éducation nationale un peu moins mais
en gros un certain nombre de choses que
fait l'état dont le nucléaire
donc je pense qu'il ya un premier
élément concerne contre le nucléaire qui
est tout simplement que ça passe dans
une marmite plus large qui est je veux
montrer que je suis indépendant et je
veux dire du mal du nucléaire et quand
on regarde où sont les émissions
d'information par ailleurs elles sont
surtout sur le service public
tf1 diffuse pas de documentaire m6 par
beaucoup enfin c'est bernard de l'alien
monsieur de la villardière la sexe
drogue et rock'n'roll nucléaire pas trop
donc le les gens qui font des
documentaires sur des sujets dits de
société un peu sérieux on va dire c'est
surtout les chefs de service public donc
à mon avis à cet effet là qui est assez
présente
le deuxième effet c'est que le nucléaire
lui même et en public en france il n'y a
pas de force de réaction
donc quand il ya un anti nucléaires pour
dire on va tous crever et qu' il ya un
ministre en exercice qui a besoin des 3
% de verre pour se faire élire
toi tu es patron de l'irs et scène où tu
t'es un peu prudent avant d'aller dire
ce mec raconte des conneries
[Musique]
maintenant il est retraité
monsieur appert à l'époque patron de
l'institut français du pétrole
bouffer un jour a vécu à côté de bercy
et il me raconte l'anecdote suivante il
me dit à l'époque des bateaux qui est
des ministres et il me dit
là j'ai rendez vous avec avec
l'administration pour négocier mon
budget jugé que vous devez peut-être
connaître
je me suis fait engueuler je me suis
fait appeler il ya trois jours la part
le dircab de bateaux à 11 heures du soir
qui m'a dit quoi vous avez posté un
document sur les gaz de schiste sur le
site de l'ump la ministre n'est pas au
courant c'est un peu comme si on disait
on à distribuer un manuel scolaire à
l'école primaire de machin chouette
c'est même belkacem est pas au courant
et et de me dire c'est un peu emmerdant
parce que je vais négocier mon budget
l'irsn est ce que dirait scène quand un
ministre reprend une connerie d'une
association antinucléaire peut dire
c'est une connerie
non parce que sinon il se met pas bien
pour son budget donc les sachants dès
qu'ils sont dans une entité de services
publics et df inclus sont mal placés
pour aller rétablir la vérité en se
précipitant sur les plateaux de
télévision parce qu'ils jouent plutôt et
je sais de quelques bruits de chiottes
qu' il ya un certain nombre de gens chez
edf qui aurait très envie d'aller se
répandre sur la place publique pour
faire de la pédagogie et justes ils le
feront jamais un à cause de ce que ce
que je viens d'expliquer
du coup on laisse le champ libre aux
gens qui sont du côté on va tous mourir
et comme tu le sais un mensonge 50 fois
répété devient une vérité donc voilà
donc c'est une combinaison des deux qui
est
et enfin le journaliste français comme
tu le sais la culture française est une
culture de rouspéteur et on aime don
quichotte
donc on aime le petit gueuleton que le
gros tu vois arriver un jeune ou une
jeune de 25 ans mignonnette etc et qui
te dit je veux sauver l'humanité le
nucléaire est une horreur était
journaliste pas quand même un peu plus
envie de le croire que toi ou moi et aux
cheveux gris et notre sérieux donc non
mais ça c'est de la psychologie humaine
de base donc la conjonction de tous ces
éléments-là fait que tu te retrouves
avec un discours qui est majoritairement
anti nucléaire alors le truc qui est
intéressant à noter quand même dans
cette affaire pour finir là-dessus c'est
que malgré un discours majoritairement
anti nucléaires dans la presse les
français ne sont pas majoritairement
anti nucléaire est à mon avis le vrai
truc intéressant à creuser c'est ça je
fais ça ne veut pas dire que fait on est
on est un peu en train de de sûr
amplifié l'influencent de la presse va
te dire tu veux vraiment écrire dans la
presse fait rire d'un whist dans
ouest-france et désinformations
vachement importante dans ouest france
est plus que dans le monde
je suis d'accord mais il faut faire de
la pédagogie d'ombré france aussi on est
on est d'accord mais je je je je pense
vraiment je vois mal comment on se sort
de la situation actuelle sans repasser
par la case pédagogie et en france on a
aussi un travers auxquelles j'ai
moi-même longtemps sacrifié qui est
pensé que si on fait un bon produit tout
le monde le sait et ce n'est pas la
peine d'avoir un service marketing et
commercial je dis non c'est pareil et
pour vendre le nucléaire à la population
française
il faut un service marketing c'est à
dire il faut des gens qui se charge de
dire voilà les avantages du truc il faut
pas les inventer faut juste que je le
redis un rapport de mise car on devrait
en parler partout il ya des chiffres qui
sont disponibles sur les comparatifs
entre charbon et nucléaire sur les morts
à court terme on devrait en parler
partout car le charbon est une horreur
absolue en termes de morts à court terme
donc ce genre de choses vraiment
j'insiste je pense que c'est pas de
l'argent du contribuable mal employés
que d'aller mettre un peu d'argent là
dedans parce que je pense que c'est un
fort effet de levier sur le reste si je
peux rajouter une petite remarque par
rapport à ce qu'il a dit c'est vrai tout
ça est vrai que les opérateurs de
recherche reçoivent leur budget de
l'état il ya et qui ont parfois du mal à
s'exprimer et en france c'est quelque
chose qui existe pour ça c'est le
principe d'indépendance des enseignants
chercheurs et les universitaires sont en
principe plus libre pour s'exprimer mais
malheureusement il n'y a pas assez de
physique nucléaire à l'université par
rapport aux écoles désordonnée de
recherche ya un déséquilibre et le il ya
un petit des intérêts de l'université
pour la chose du clairet ça c'est
dommage parce que là il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à faire de ce côté là
bonjour j'ai une question vous avez
parlé de transition
l'énergétique plateau dans les pays
développés il ya une explosion
démographique attendue notamment en
afrique dans les décennies qui arrivent
ces gens ils vont vouloir de
l'électricité et si vous pensez que le
nucléaire ça peut être une solution pour
eux ou est-ce que ce serait pas
déployables dans les temps
la réponse est oui en particulier un
truc que j'ai vu que j'ai trouvé assez
malin dans tout ce que j'ai vu en
matière de nucléaire c'est le projet
flexblue de dcns
[Musique]
alors ça nous renvoie à la question
précédente selon une maxime ces lettres
de mon école qui est la question du
public accepte ans
vous ferez jamais financé un truc comme
ça par le pays en direct dont vous aurez
besoin des bailleurs de fonds bilatéraux
ou multilatéraux qui jamais ne
financerons quoi que ce soit qui porte
le nom du portugais becquerels dans
l'état actuel de publicat 76 dollars
de leurs opinions domestique une fois
ceci dit donc il n'est pas un problème
mineur
je trouve que c'est un truc qui est pas
idiot ce projet parce que vous avez pas
besoin d'infrastructures lourdes à terre
pour aller installer ce genre de choses
alors c'est un tout petit peu coloniale
parce que c'est une manière de dire
attendez vous à faire à votre place mais
en attendant si c'est un deal qui est
accepté je trouve que c'est pas
inintéressant et
il ya également quelque chose qui
pourrait être intéressant plus tard
alors j'ai essayé d'en parler un peu à
me dis moi c'est un truc que je connais
mal mais ça me gratte donc c'est le
domaine du nucléaire dont jaked j'ai
envie de me perfectionner à titre
personnel pour essayer d'y comprendre
quelque chose
c'est les réacteurs au thorium à sel
fondu parce que sur le papier ça a l'air
très intéressant petit sécurité passive
et c'est donc vous dites c'est
typiquement le genre de boîte que je
vais pouvoir mettre quelque part sans
sans que ce soit très ennuyeux c'est pas
pour tout de suite mais ça peut être
aussi une forme de réponse
il n'empêche que pour dire un truc
essentiel que je n'ai pas dit jusqu'à
maintenant l'essentiel du problème que
j'ai évoquées jusqu'à l'instant c'est à
dire la décrue énergétique en occident
et le problème du changement climatique
va se régler non pas part du nucléaire
mais par des économies quand même dû
préciser ça et il ya un certain nombre
d'endroits je suis pas du tout anti
renouvelables ou les renouvelables ont
un rôle majeur à jouer et pour finir
là-dessus sur les renouvelables
en tant que contribuable français plutôt
que d'aller mettre 100 milliards d'euros
parce que c'est à peu près ce qu'on va
mettre dans des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires en france qui ne
servent à rien d'autre qu'à engraisser
les producteurs d'anouar que j'adore on
est européen et les producteurs chinois
que j'adore etc
on aurait donné entendez bien de donner
cet argent aux marocains ou algériens et
aux tunisiens pour développer chez eux
des systèmes renouvelables solaire à
concentration
éoliennes plus tech vous pouvez faire
des stations de pompage dans l'atlas
avec l'eau de la méditerranée par
exemple quand vous emmerdez un scorpion
et de lézards pas très grave
donc on aurait pu faire ce genre de
trucs et ben moi j'aurais signé quatre
mains qu'on fasse ce genre de truc parce
que par ailleurs sa aurai sédentarisés
une population jeune en croissance avec
a besoin de projets sur la rive sud de
la méditerranée et je pense que vos
copains ils apprécieraient aussi on fait
ce genre de choses
donc le
enfin sauf à ce qu'il y ait très envie
de faire joujou avec les maigres avion
que le budget voudra bien leur payer
mais sinon je pense que c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'on aurait dû faire
donc vous voyez je suis pas du tout
entier renouvelables je suis juste en
train de dire quand on est dans une
course contre la montre il n'allons pas
mettre notre argent qui est précieux
dans des trucs qui servent à rien
utilisons le pour des trucs qui servent
donc pour finir sur l'afrique
il ya plein de trucs à dire sur
l'afrique les deux autres trucs que je
vous dirais c'est le nucléaire oui
peut-être mais avec des projets qui
toute façon sont un peu longues choc
parce qu'aujourd'hui le contexte
d'implémentation n'y est pas et à très
bref délai c'est les nerfs en afrique de
manière absolument évidente
et je préfèrerais que mon argent aille
les aider à faire ce genre de truc de
manière intelligente plutôt que de faire
des conneries chine merci je vous
remercie je nous allons arrêter lorsque
le temps tourne merci beaucoup pour
cette conférence ces échanges
[Applaudissements]